frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Herren und
Damen guten Morgen eigentlich haben wir
besseres und Wichtigeres zu tun als
übereinander zu reden die Wirklichkeit
fordert unsere volle Konzentration und
Aufmerksamkeit dennoch möchte ich einmal
sagen dass der Sound der
selbstkritiklosigkeit den ich hier
gestern gehört habe eine Antwort
erfordert lieber Herr Merz 16 Jahre lang
hat die Union dieses langen kreiert und
viele Bundesländer 16 Jahre
energiepolitisches versagen und wir
räumen in wenigen Monaten auf was sie in
16 Jahren verbockt verhindert und
zerstört haben sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
und das tun wir mit einigen Erfolg seit
einer Woche gibt es kein Gas aus
Russland die Speicher füllen sich weiter
nach einem kurzen Ausschlag in der Börse
ist der Preis noch immer hoch und zu
hoch aber nicht explodiert seit einer
Woche sind wir unabhängig von russischem
Gas wegen der konsequenten und
vorausschauenden Handlungsfähigkeit
dieser Regierung und dieser Koalition
gestern hat Frankreich nachdem es immer
Abnehmerland war erstmals Gas nach
Deutschland geredet Erfolg von
diplomatischen Anstrengungen und
Bemühungen es war ein Testbetrieb
dennoch gleichzeitig ein historischer
dann ist verstärkt die europäische
Solidarität sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
dass wir da stehen wo wir sind liegt
daran dass diese Regierung von Tag eins
an einen konsequenten Kurs gefahren hat
und wusste wohin sie will und weiß was
die Not des Tages erfordert nämlich ein
bekämpfen der aktuellen Krise bei
Beibehalten der strukturellen
notwendigen Veränderungen die dieses
Land in die Zukunft führen wird deswegen
haben wir immer alle Maßnahmen mit der
notwendigen Transformation kombiniert
die Energieeffizienz der Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren war immer integraler
Bestandteil unserer Politik und dass die
Union in dieser Krise in dieser
Wirtschaftskrise ernsthaft dagegen klagt
dass die notwendigen Investitionen in
erneuerbare Energien in Energieeffizienz
in Wasserstoff hochlauft und auch noch
in die Robustheit der Unternehmen
verfassungswidrig sein soll das ist
ökonomischer Wahnsinn meine Damen und
Herren wie wollen Sie denn den
Unternehmen wie wollen Sie denn den
Unternehmen erklären dass sie am Ende in
dieser Situation wo wir einen
nachfrageschock haben keine staatlichen
Unterstützung mehr bekommen es zeigt
bestfossilen geisteskind sie noch immer
sind
ich habe manchmal den Eindruck dass sie
überhaupt noch nicht verstanden haben
welchen Ausmaß die Herausforderungen der
Zeit
erfordern welche Anstrengungen wir
nehmen müssen welche Umstellung auch in
der Art wie wir Politik denken notwendig
sind stattdessen immer nur weiter das
Opposition zu
oppositionsklänge und möchtegern
Wirtschaftspolitik sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
was ist das wichtigste
das Wichtigste ist dass wir die
preismanipulation durch Putin beenden
wir können auf Dauer nicht gegen die
hohen Preise anzupensionieren deswegen
müssen wir jetzt und werden wir das
energiemarkdesign so ändern dass die
günstigen Kosten an die Verbraucher
weitergegeben werden und die hohen
Kosten zwar noch den Marktmechanismus
geben aber nicht mehr durchgereicht
werden morgen ist der energieministerrat
in Brüssel die Vorschläge der Kommission
liegen vor man sieht wie gut Europa
arbeiten kann und sie gehen sehr in die
Richtung die auch wir vorgeschlagen
haben da sind wir auf einem guten Weg
aber auch das muss man aussprechen wir
machen etwas in wenigen Wochen was
normalerweise Jahre wahrscheinlich zwei
Jahre Beratung gebraucht hätte wir gehen
an das stromagdesign rein und wir halten
uns eine Option offen wenn das nicht
sofort und solide gelingt dann werden
wir über eine abschöpfungsabgabe die
Gewinne kassieren und den Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern zurückgeben
wir werden
auch
wir werden auch beim Gaspreis etwas
machen müssen wenngleich komplizierter
aber es ist nicht richtig dass wir uns
in eine Situation hineinbegeben wo wir
es für jeden Preis einkaufen wir werden
auch dort Mechanismen finden und den
Gaspreis herunterbringen wir stoppen
damit den Abschluss des Geldes ins
europäische oder ins globale Ausland und
wir stoppen es am stärksten
perspektivisch in dem wir uns nicht nur
von russischen Energien sondern von den
fossilen Energien insgesamt losmachen
wer das verkennt wer das verkennt
verkennt in welcher Phase wir uns
eigentlich befinden bis wir die Preise
runter bekommen haben und das wird
sicherlich ein bisschen dauern bis wir
die Preise runter bekommen haben werden
wir den Unternehmen jede Hilfe zukommen
lassen wir werden einen breiten
Rettungsschirm aufspannen und wir werden
ihn bereit auf spannen so dass vor allem
die kleinen und und die die KMU's unter
diesen Rettungsschirm runterfallen
können was heißt das konkret wir werden
das Programm dass wir jetzt aufgestellt
haben für die Industrie das
Energiekosten dämpfungsprogramm öffnen
für KMU's wir werden damit die
handelsbezogenheit als Kriterium die
handelsbezogenheit als Kriterium
aufgeben wir werden es branchenöffnen
gestalten aber an Kriterien natürlich
festhalten Kriterien kann beispielsweise
der Energiekostenanteil an Produkt oder
am Umsatz sein es wird zeitlich
befristet sein weil wir einen anderen
Instrumenten arbeiten nämlich die Preise
stoppen und so die Unternehmen und die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger entlasten es kann
also keine Dauer Subvention sein aber
dieses Programm wird aufgelegt werden
und es wird der deutschen Wirtschaft den
Weg in diese neue Zukunft erleichtern
beziehungsweise dafür sorgen dass wir
ihnen gehen können wir werden wir werden
die deutschen Unternehmen und dem
deutschen Mittelstand schützen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren nicht alle
Unternehmen leiden unter den hohen
Energiekosten wir haben einen
nachfrageschock das Geld in den
Haushalten wird knapp und deswegen
werden wir im weiteren Maßnahmen
wirtschaftspolitische wie vor allem
strukturelle Maßnahmen ergreifen müssen
dass die Menschen in Deutschland genug
Geld haben auch zu konsumieren und so
die Unternehmen stützen können
beziehungsweise Unternehmen ebenfalls
geschützt werden die nicht nur alleine
über die in die energieintensive
Produktionsweise von dem Programm wie
eben skizziert erfasst werden und
fünftens werden wir im Oktober einen
Mechanismus auflegen wo Gas gegen Geld
den Gasverbrauch unterbringt und die
Unternehmen die dann in der Produktion
etwas zurückfahren schützt und
finanziell entschädigt sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren Putins Angriff zielt
auch auf unser Wirtschaftssystem es wird
immer gesagt es ist die schwerste
Energiekrise seit 1973 das ist nicht
richtig diese Energiekrise ist weit
komplexer die Aufgaben sind weit größer
und deswegen müssen wir das was im
Normalfall gut funktioniert jetzt
hinterfragen und ändern wir müssen das
Marktdesign am Strommarkt ändern wir
müssen die fiskalpolitischen Rahmen neu
denken wir müssen die Geschwindigkeit
und die Entschlossenheit mit der
politische Entscheidung fällen über
hinterfragen und verändern wie wir es
getan haben und wir sollten vielleicht
auch überdenken in welcher Rolle
Opposition und Regierung sich manchmal
befinden sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
vielen Dank
mit Kritik an der Union an wie er sagt
fehlender Selbstkritik bezüglich der
Energiepolitik der vergangenen Jahre hat
der Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck
die Debatte über seinen Etappe 2023
eröffnet Energie in allen Facetten wird
beherrschendes Thema dieser Aussprache
sein auch in der ersten Rede aus der
Opposition und da steht schon bereit
Jens Spahn einer der stellvertretenden
Vorsitzenden der cdu/csu-fraktion
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Jens Spahn
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen jede Kilowattstunde zählt das
ist ihr Mantra in dieser Krise Herr
Minister damit begründen sie duschtipps
und einsparverordnung denn wenn in
dieser Krise aber jede Kilowattstunde
zählt dann müssen wir schon fragen ob
dieses Mantra dieses Motto auch für ihre
Regierung und ihr Handeln gilt denn wenn
jede Kilowattstunde zählt dann zählt
auch jede Form jede Form der möglichen
Energieerzeugung die hier in Deutschland
möglich ist und da tun sie nicht
da tun sie nicht was geht sie nutzen das
Potenzial von Biomasse Biogas nicht sie
haben unseren Antrag im Juli hier
abgelehnt im Sommer haben sie gesagt
jetzt wollen sie es doch tun ein
konkreten regelungsvorschlag haben wir
bis jetzt nicht wir nutzen die
Erneuerbaren klimaneutralen
Möglichkeiten beim Biogas seit Monaten
nicht und das ist Ihr Versäumnis
Kohle Kohle wir haben hier im März
gesagt Kohlekraftwerke aus der Reserve
hochfahren um beim Gas die Verstromung
runterzufahren da haben sie noch gelacht
im Juli haben Sie dann die Gesetze
geändert um es tun zu wollen muss man ja
sagen mittlerweile zweieinhalb Monate
später sind zwei in Worten zwei
Kohlekraftwerke nur neu am Netz wegen
ihrer bürokratischen Vorgaben weil sie
zu spät gehandelt haben wenn jede
Kilowattstunde zählt dann hätten diese
Kohlekraftwerke schon längst am Netz
sein müssen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und dann Kernkraft sechs Monate Debatte
mit verschleppen Falschaussagen Streit
sie hätten am Montagabend einen
Befreiungsschlag machen können für Klima
Schutz und Versorgungssicherheit
stattdessen haben sie das Chaos
perfektioniert sie handeln gegen die
Empfehlung des Stresstests der
ausdrücklich sagt die drei
Kernkraftwerke im streckbetrieb zu
lassen sie haben uns immer gesagt es
ginge nicht Personal man müsste Gesetze
ändern Sicherheitsanforderungen jetzt
machen sie genau das sie ändern das
Gesetz sie halten das Personal sie
stellen die Sicherheit sicher nur sie
produzieren keinen Strom das ist das
Problem an ihrer Lösung
Familien Handwerker Pflegeheime haben
jeden Tag Stresstest seit Monaten die
können nämlich ihre Stromrechnung nicht
mehr bezahlen und Stromrechnung
Strompreise sind deswegen hoch weil das
Angebot in Europa zu niedrig ist und das
heißt jedes Kraftwerk muss ans Netz aber
Herr Minister
das Kernkraftwerk in Lingen das ist nur
wirklich die Spitze des ihrsinns sie
wollen das ist der Vorschlag
ölkraftwerke auf Schiffen
zu teuren Preisen anmieten um im
Norddeutschland die Netzstabilität zu
gewährleisten anstatt das
klimaneutrale Kernkraftwerken zu lassen
wer hier den Geist von fossilen Energien
hat das können wir da gerne mal
diskutieren nur weil ihre
nur weil ihre Wahlkämpfer in
Niedersachsen bei bei Atomen auf die
Plakate geklebt haben lassen sie als
grüner klimaminister lieber ölkraftwerke
auf Schiffen laufen anstatt ein sicheres
Kernkraftwerk und ich finde das ist
Harakiri in der Lage in der wir aktuell
sind
und Gaspreise das ist die Lehrstelle
auch ihres entlastungspaketes beim
drängsten Thema von 20 Millionen
deutschen und vielen Unternehmen nichts
keine Lösung stattdessen die gasumlage
wie sagte jemand zu treffend Deutschland
ist wenn die Regierung plant per Umlage
auch Konzerne mit Milliardengewinne zu
subventionieren dafür dann die
Mehrwertsteuer gesenkt wird um von der
Umlage betroffene Verbraucher zu
entlasten um dann über eine
übergewinnsteuer die Unternehmen die
profitieren dann wieder zu belasten
stoppen Sie diese chaosumlage stoppen
Sie diesen Irrsinn stimmen sie nachher
unserem Antrag zu das aufzuheben liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und geben Sie vor allem den Menschen
Sicherheit für diesen Winter bei Gas und
bei Strom
strompreisbremse keiner weiß wann in
welcher Höhe beim Gas gar kein Angebot
für jeden Haushalt verlässlich einen
Grundbedarf 75% des vorjahresverbrauches
definieren und Sicherheit geben für
diesen Winter das bräuchten wir dringend
denn frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen Deutschland steht ein
schwerer Winter ins Haus Deutschland und
die Deutschen werden ärmer jeden Tag
wegen hoher Gas und Strompreise wir
sollten alles tun soziale Not zu lindern
Familien Handwerkern der Wirtschaft in
dieser schwierigen Zeit zu helfen wir
haben wir haben wir haben ihn wir haben
ihn mehrfach
wir haben ihn mehr haben ihnen mehrfach
Angeboten jetzt warten Sie doch mal wir
haben ihnen mehrfach Angeboten Herr
Minister in dieser schweren Zeit mit in
die Verantwortung zu gehen
Kompromisse zu suchen das haben sie
abgelehnt sie sind ihren Weg gegangen
und das finde ich haben sie gerade auch
in der Art noch mal sehr sehr deutlich
gemacht das ist ihr gutes Recht sie
haben die Mehrheit aber damit ist eins
auch klar in diesem Winter sind
Höchstpreise bei Strom und Gas in diesem
Winter ist die Unsicherheit von
Millionen Menschen im Land ist jeder
Strom und gasausfall ist jede Insolvenz
und jede Betriebsaufgabe dann auch ihre
Verantwortung reden sie sich nicht mit
16 Jahren raus es geht hier um ihr
Krisenmanagement seit sechs Monaten
darum geht es
Deutschland und die deutschen bräuchten
in dieser Lage nichts Deutschland und
die deutschen bräuchten in dieser Lage
nichts mehr als Zuversicht und
Zusammenhalt
Deutschland und den deutschen bräuchten
in dieser Lage nichts mehr als
Zuversicht und Zusammenhalt und Sie
müssen sich die Frage stellen ob die
Entscheidungen die sie treffen und die
Art wie sie Politik machen wirklich
geeignet sind Zuversicht und
Zusammenhalt im Land zu stärken mein
Eindruck ist das nicht
Jens Spahn mit deutlichen Worten aus
seiner Perspektive in Richtung
Regierungsbank und in Richtung
ampelchorlitzion das war ein bisschen
absehbar wie diese Debatte hier
verlaufen wird zum Etat des
Wirtschaftsministers aber sie merken das
Thema Energie ist tatsächlich das
beherrschende hier heute nächster Redner
wird Matthias Miersch sein
stellvertretender Vorsitzender der
SPD-Fraktion und mit großem Interesse
wird übrigens auch der Redebeitrag von
Sahra Wagenknecht aus der aus der
Linksfraktion erwartet die ist in Kürze
schon dran erstmal Matthias misch
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Herr Spahn sie haben eben gewünscht dass
wir auf sie hören dass sie mit
Verantwortung übernehmen können sie
haben viele Jahre hier Verantwortung
getragen
und sicherlich war nicht alles schlecht
in der großen Koalition aber das Thema
Energiepolitik wenn dort eine Ampel die
letzten 16 Jahre regiert hätte wären wir
jetzt tatsächlich zukunftsfest liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wenn sie und wenn sie auch jetzt
noch in die Verantwortung gehen wollen
dann sage ich ihnen ich bin heilfroh
dass sie es nicht sind nun ist das
energiepolitisch bei ihnen nicht so sie
haben einen anderen Fachbereich gehabt
deswegen nehme ich Ihnen das nicht so
ganz übel aber hier so dicke Sprüche zu
machen und dann Vorschläge zu machen die
dieses Land bereits im Frühjahr in die
Knie gezwungen hätte da finde ich ein
gewisse Selbstreflexion wäre angesagt
und Herr Merz als Partei und
Fraktionsvorsitzender der gestern große
Worte findet sie haben hier
im März deswegen kann man sich gut
merken der märzspruch sie haben hier im
März ein Gas embargo gefordert wir wären
jetzt keine es wäre keine Möglichkeit
gewesen sie Speicher zu füllen die
Preise werden vorher schon explodiert
wenn wir Ihnen die Verantwortung gegeben
hätten
das ist die Wahrheit und damit müssen
sie sich auseinandersetzen und nicht ein
Bundeswirtschaftsminister kritisieren
der Tag und Nacht versucht auch
Versäumnisse ihrer Politik wegzumachen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
aber richtig ist
wir leben in Zeiten die diese
Gesellschaft auch vor große
Herausforderungen stellt und wir wissen
gestern wieder einmal dass es Gruppen in
diesem Haus gibt die sagen es muss
diesem Volk schlecht gehen weil wir dann
politisch Profit daraus ziehen wollen
und ich bin Ihnen dankbar Herr Merz dass
sie gestern noch mal bekannt haben alle
demokratischen Parteien müssen hier
zusammenhalten und dieser Populismus
darf nicht durchgehen
aber
wenn man diesen
Populismus bekämpfen will
dann muss man sehr aufpassen bei der
Argumentation die man hier als
Opposition vorbringt
denn die Menschen haben zu Recht finde
nicht die Erwartung dass wir hier
streiten um den besten Weg aber wir
müssen auch um belastbare Lösungen
streiten und ich will ihnen das an
dieser Stelle sagen so wie sie mit dem
Thema Atom in den letzten Monaten
umgegangen sind ist es für mich reiner
Populismus die Atomkraft als Lösung in
dieser Phase zu sehen ist eine Sackgasse
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
warum haben wir denn das Problem weil
augenblicklich 32 der 56 Atomkraftwerke
in Frankreich nicht am Netz sind liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und warum haben wir ein Problem im Süden
Deutschlands weil ihre Regierung in
Bayern alles unterlassen hat was an
Thema erneuerbare notwendig gewesen wäre
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wenn sie suggerieren durch die
Zuschaltung und Laufzeitverlängerung von
drei Atomkraftwerken würde sich beim
Preis etwas ändern dann machen sie den
Menschen etwas vor atomkraft ist nicht
preismindern liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
es gibt es gibt nur einen Weg
augenblicklich die Preisspirale in den
Griff zu bekommen und der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister hat zu Recht
darauf hingewiesen es muss ins System
eingegriffen werden und deswegen ist es
richtig was am Samstag beschlossen
worden ist
und wenn sie sagen
ja wir machen das mit dem Stresstest und
dann muss es noch eine
Laufzeitverlängerung geben dann will ich
Ihnen schon sagen es ist elf Jahre her
elf Jahre dann die Bundeskanzlerin
Merkel an dieser Stelle gesagt in
Fukushima haben wir zur Kenntnis nehmen
müssen dass selbst in einem
Hochtechnologieland wie Japan die
Risiken der Kernkraft nicht sicher
beherrscht werden können daraus ist eine
riesen Diskussion entstanden und wir
haben alle in diesem Haus den
Ausstiegsbeschluss einvernehmlich
gefasst weil wir wussten dass Atomkraft
keine Lösung ist liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
aber ich unterstelle Ihnen sie haben es
aus machttaktischen Gründen gemacht sie
sind nie davon überzeugt gewesen und
deswegen kommt jetzt sofort wieder eine
Scheinlösung die sie hier präsentieren
weil sie parallel dazu die letzten Jahre
im alles auch getan haben um den Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien zu verhindern
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wenn sie suggerieren dass sie durch
die Laufzeitverlängerung
Versorgungssicherheit sicherstellen
könnten dann sage ich ihnen setzen sie
wieder aufs falsche Pferd was wir
brauchen ist in der Tat die reservekraft
die wir jetzt bei Kohle zur Verfügung
stellen auch das Schöpfen von Biogas etc
aber den maximalen Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien in den nächsten
Monaten liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und und das sage ich für die
SPD-Fraktion auch hier im Bereich der
Wärme muss das was die Regierung
vorgedacht hat beim Thema Strompreis
auch Realität werden auch beim Thema
Gast auch beim Thema Wärme brauchen wir
systemische Eingriffe in dem Markt wir
können nicht gegen subventionieren wenn
Preise explodieren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und wir sind sicher dass die
eingesetzte Kommission denn nichts ist
trivial aber in den nächsten Wochen
belastbare Vorschläge diesen Parlament
macht damit wir auch Wärme in den Griff
bekommen und für verbrauchen und
Verbraucher und Unternehmen Sicherheit
in diesem elementaren Bereich
gewährleisten können liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
aber wir wissen auch dass alles besser
ist wenn wir es europäisch machen und
deswegen lieber Robert Habeck alles Gute
für morgen die Europäische Union das
will ich hier betonen steht vor einer
großen Belastungsprobe es muss geliefert
werden wenn nicht geliefert wird müssen
wir hier nationalstaatlich in diesen
Elementen Vorgehen das steht für uns als
sozialdemokratischer Fraktion fest
Energie ist Daseinsvorsorge wir brauchen
einen starken Staat der den Menschen
jetzt Sicherheit gibt vielen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Matthias mir stellvertretender
Vorsitzender der SPD-Fraktion nennt den
Versuch eine mögliche Energie Lücke mit
Atomenergie zu schließen eine Sackgasse
und eine Scheinlösung ist ist hier viel
Vergangenheitsbewältigung auch in dieser
Debatte nächster Redner der einer der
stellvertretenden Vorsitzende der
afd-fraktion Live Erik Holm
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
Herr Minister sie haben von der
fehlenden Selbstkritik der Union
gesprochen dass wir uns völlig einig 16
Jahre lang haben sie an diesem Murks
mitgewirkt aber ich vermisse bei ihnen
noch mal ein kleines bisschen
Selbstreflexion im Angesicht des Murks
den Sie hier noch schlimmer betreiben in
dieser ampelregierung die verkaufste und
unsoziale gasumlage die Abschaltung
moderner Kernkraftwerke das unsinnige
Insolvenz Geplapper bei Maischberger die
letzten Tage haben noch klar gezeigt
dieser Minister und diese Regierung sie
können das einfach nicht wir werden
regiert von energiepolitischen
Geisterfahrern
selbst jetzt im Angesicht von
Preisexplosionen und dramatischen
Knappheiten bleiben Sie weiter auf der
Gegend Fahrbahn und wollen den
Energiewende Wahnsinn noch weiter
treiben während sie funktionierende
Kraftwerke abschalten das kann man auch
wirklich niemandem erklären was sind die
für Traumtänzer unterwegs
machen sie die Augen auf
Millionen Bürger haben Angst ihre
Rechnung für Strom und Gas bald nicht
mehr bezahlen zu können immer mehr
Unternehmen gehen in die Insolvenz ein
Anstieg wird erwartet für Oktober von
einem Drittel sagt das Leibniz-Institut
hackle Görtz waren die ersten Vorboten
gestern dr Schneider in meiner Heimat
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern steckt fast die
Hälfte der Bäckereien schon in
finanziellen Schwierigkeiten wegen der
explodierenden Preise und sie erklären
den im Fernsehen Herr Minister dass sie
gar nicht Insolvenz müssten sondern ja
mal vorübergehend die Produktion
einstellen könnten das wirkt nicht nur
schräg sondern kommt als hohen an bei
Unternehmen die tagtäglich um ihre
Existenz kämpfen
man muss sich das ja mal vorstellen
Unternehmen und Ihre Mitarbeiter wissen
kaum noch wie es weitergehen soll und
sie wollen die sichersten und modernsten
Kernkraftwerke der Welt abschalten die
zur Senkung des Strompreises hätten
beitragen können mehr Angebot bedeutet
geringere Preise es wäre so einfach
gewesen sie hätten einfach diese
Ankündigung am Montag machen können
Laufzeitverlängerung und sofort wäre der
Future Strompreis fürs nächste Jahr
gefallen das wäre schnelle Hilfe für die
Bürger gewesen und für die Unternehmen
und sie verweigern diese Hilfe da
betreiben sie immer mehr Bürger und
Unternehmen in existenzielle Not man
muss es klar sagen die Preistreiber die
sitzen hier vorne auf der Regierungsbank
unsere Nachbarländer bauen ihre
Kapazitäten aus wir bauen sie ab was ist
daran solidarische Minister das ist doch
keine Solidarität das ist das Gegenteil
wir sind die energieparasiten dieses
Europas das ist schlimm peinlich
stattdessen setzen sie auf eine
Entlastungspaket das allein die Symptome
bekämpft und wieder viele außen vor
lässt die Unternehmen die von der
Mehrwertsteuersenkung bei der gasumlage
gar nichts haben zum Beispiel viele
fleißige die noch jeden Tag zur Arbeit
fahren für wenig Geld aber nichts von
ihren Zuschüssen haben weil sie eben
noch arbeiten gehen das ist nicht
gerecht und was ist mit den Menschen auf
dem Land den haben sie drei Monate einen
trostpflasterchen gegeben Tankrabatt ist
schon wieder vorbei warum eigentlich das
war eine sinnvolle Maßnahme wir müssen
runter von den Energiesteuern dass das
einzige was der Staat an dieser Stelle
machen kann um die Inflation einzudämmen
und den Bürgern mehr Geld in der Tasche
zu lassen diese energiesteuersenkung
beim Tanken sie muss kommen sie muss
bleiben dauerhaft es kommt nichts von
ihnen
meine Damen und Herren wir müssen die
richtigen Entscheidungen treffen die
sind jetzt zu treffen die Kernkraftwerke
müssen weiterlaufen und die drei die vom
Netz genommen worden im letzten Jahr
müssen wieder angefahren werden das
brauchen wir jetzt wir brauchen auch
keine vorschnellen Sanktionen die nur
uns selber schaden und wir brauchen
keine Steuern und Abgaben auf Sprit auf
Gas und Strom die den Menschen kein Geld
mehr in der Tasche lassen runter mit den
Energie steuern das kann der Staat jetzt
tun das muss er tun ihr Weg ihr Weg
führt geradewegs in die Katastrophe wenn
Sie den weitergeht übrigens die Bäcker
letzter Satz die Bäcker in
Norddeutschland die Bäcker in
Norddeutschland gehen heute auf die
Straße und sagen bei uns gehen bald die
Lichter aus und wenn sie so weitermachen
dann wird es in Deutschland nicht nur
symbolisch sondern wirklich zappenduster
vielen Dank
der Bundestag berät und diskutiert in
erster Lesung über den Etat des
Bundesministeriums für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz und habe ich garantiert
nicht alle Debatten zum Etat des
Wirtschaftsministeriums gesehen aber ich
wage mal die These das hier ist eine der
lebendigsten und ein bisschen auch
aufgeregtesten die wir heute haben
Karsten klein ist der nächste Redner er
ist ob man im Haushaltsausschuss und
kommt aus der FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Stabilität
der Gesellschaft der soziale Frieden die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung und der
Wohlstand sind durch die Inflation
gefährdet Inflation sorgt für
Unsicherheit steigende Kosten gefährdet
unsere Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und damit
auch die Arbeitsplätze jetzt ist es
außer Frage dass die originäre Aufgabe
zur Preisentwicklung zur
preissteigerungsbekämpfung die EZB hat
die Europäische Zentralbank aber jetzt
sind wir keine Zuschauer auch wenn wir
natürlich der Meinung sind dass die EZB
viel zu zarker viel zu langsam reagiert
hat aber deshalb müssen wir auf der
politischen Bühne trotzdem die
Bekämpfung der Inflation flankieren und
das tun die Herr Minister durch zwei
Maßnahmen das eine ist die
Schuldenbremse und das andere ist die
kalte Progression die Schuldenbremse
sorgt dafür dass wir keine expandive
expansive Ausgabenpolitik haben denn es
wäre fatal wenn der Staat die Nachfrage
nach knappen Gütern auch noch anheizt
da ist die Schuldenbremse ein wichtiges
Instrument zur Inflationsbekämpfung
und die Bekämpfung der kalten
Progression die führt dazu dass die
Lohnerhöhung auch bei den Bürgerinnen
und Bürger bei den Menschen ankommt
statt beim Staat und sie verhindert dass
es zu einer lungenpreisspirale kommt und
deshalb Herr Minister brauchen wir für
die Inflationsbekämpfung eine klaren
Kurs und auch eine klare Unterstützung
des Wirtschaftsministers weil die
Inflation so eine große Gefahr für die
Wirtschaft darstellt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
zweite Thema weil ich ansprechen will
ist natürlich die Energieversorgung
Energiesicherheit das Energie überhaupt
zur Verfügung steht das Vergessen ja
manche und auch die Bezahlbarkeit der
Energie und weil es in Deutschland in
der Diskussion ja so ein bisschen in
Vergessenheit gerät der Ausgangspunkt
für die Energieproblematik die wir haben
ist der verbrecherische Krieg von
Vladimir Putin in der Ukraine und das
ist das Wladimir Putin Energie als Waffe
gegen unsere Freiheit demokratische
Gesellschaft einsetzt es ist nicht so
dass die Bundesregierung hier wie man
der ein oder andere behauptet die Preise
irgendwie anfangen würde sondern der
Grund dafür sitzt in Moskau
nichtsdestotrotz hat die Bundesregierung
und die sie tragenden Fraktion ja ein
ganzer Anzahl von Maßnahmen auf dem Weg
gebracht um die Versorgungssicherheit
sicherzustellen um die Preisentwicklung
abzudämpfen bei der
Versorgungssicherheit will ich in der
Kürze nur auf die lng-terminals eingehen
die und die nächsten zehn Jahren 2,7
Milliarden Euro kosten werden oder dass
wir es ermöglicht haben für 15
Milliarden Euro Gas zu beschaffen das in
unsere garsp eingelagert werden kann und
wir werden in den Haushaltsberatungen
Minister auch dafür sorgen tragen dass
der Speicher der für Bayern zuständig
ist aber in Österreich sitzt auch ein
Einspeisung einer Einspeisung erfährt
aber
wir müssen natürlich weiterhin die
Preise im Blick haben Herr Minister und
deshalb ist es umso wichtiger dass die
jetzt beschlossene Strompreis Bremse am
Wochenende auch schnell umgesetzt wird
denn wir wollen dass diese negative
EEG-Umlage die Entlastung bei dem
Haushalten und bei den kleinen und
mittleren Unternehmen bei dem Bäcker und
Metzger auch ankommen weil wir die eben
in dieser Krise nicht vergessen und uns
wichtig sind
aber dazu Herr Minister gehört aus dass
wir Druck aus dem System insgesamt
nehmen wir verstromen immer noch zu viel
Gas wir erzeugen zu viel Strom aus Gas
und deshalb müssen wir das substituieren
durch mehr Kohle und durch mehr
Atomkraft eine Reservebetrieb in den am
Anfang des nächsten Jahres ist zu wenig
wir brauchen ein Weiterbetrieb dieser
Realität müssen Sie sich stellen
und natürlich neben den kleinen und
mittleren Unternehmen
haben wir auch den Blick auf die großen
und energieintensiven Unternehmen dafür
haben wir ja ein großes Paket auch
geschnürt mit 4 Milliarden Euro im
Haushalt um diese Unternehmen zu
unterstützen jetzt steht es außer Frage
und deshalb hätte ich schon ein bisschen
mehr Demut auch von der Union erwartet
sie haben ja sehr große Baustellen
übernommen von ihrem Vorgänger in
jeglichen Bereich große
Herausforderungen daueraufgaben
Klimawandel Energiewende Fachkräfte
Sicherung auch im Bereich der Raumfahrt
die großen Posten finanziell auch in
ihrem Etat indem wir in der letzten vier
Jahren eine schlafwagenpolitik erlebt
haben wir haben
bundesrechnungshofberichte in denen klar
drinsteht dass bei der Wirksamkeit der
Einsetzung von Steuermitteln und sie
haben erhebliche Steuermittel jetzt auch
wieder zur Verfügung mit 13 Milliarden
Euro 1,7 Milliarden Euro mehr als in
2022 das bei diesem Einsatz der
Steuermittel nicht wirksam vorgegangen
wird nicht koordiniert vorgegangen wird
das hat ihr Vorgänger Ihnen als große
Baustelle überlassen aber ich erwarte
auch von Innenminister dass sie diese
System in ihrem Haus abstellen denn
letztendlich haben die BürgerInnen der
BürgerInnen ein Anrecht darauf dass wir
natürlich die energiesicherung die
Energieversorgung sicherstellen aber
dass wir auch mit den Steuermitteln am
Ende wirksam und zielgerichtet vorgehen
und diese verausgaben und dafür werden
wir in den Haushaltsberatungen sicher
noch einiges zu tun haben vielen Dank
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Carsten klein war das ob man in der
FDP-Fraktion im
Haushaltsausschuss und wie schon vorhin
mal angekündigt mit einem etwas größeren
Interesse erwartet Sahra Wagenknecht aus
der Linksfraktion
und das größere Interesse bezog sich auf
die eigenen Reihenfolgen ihre eigenen
Reihen
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren in Deutschland bahnt sich eine
soziale und wirtschaftliche Katastrophe
an Millionen Menschen haben Angst vor
der Zukunft vor explodierende
Lebenshaltungskosten wo
horrorabrechnungen und immer mehr auch
um ihren Arbeitsplatz und auch wenn es
sich noch nicht bis ins
Wirtschaftsministerium herumgesprochen
hat in Schlüsselindustrien werden
Betriebe reihenweise schließen schreibt
das Handelsblatt denn Herr Habeck in der
Wirtschaft ist das leider nicht so wie
in der Politik ein Minister der nichts
mehr liefert muss leider tatsächlich
keine Insolvenz anmelden sie sind das
beste Beispiel dafür
aber ein Unternehmen ein Unternehmen das
wegen der hohen Preise nichts mehr
verkaufen kann das verschwindet vom
Markt und das heißt eben schlicht im
Klartext wenn wir die Energiepreis
Explosion nicht stoppen dann wird die
deutsche Industrie mit ihrem starken
Mittelstand bald nur noch ein Erinnerung
an die guten alten Zeiten sein und die
hohen Energiepreise viel höher als in
vielen anderen europäischen Ländern die
sind doch nicht vom Himmel gefallen die
sind doch das Ergebnis von Politik sie
sind zum einen das Ergebnis ihrer
völligen rückgratlosigkeit gegenüber den
absahnern und krisenprofiteuren die
Mineralölkonzerne werden in diesem Jahr
in Deutschland 38 Milliarden Euro mehr
Gewinne machen als im Schnitt der
letzten Jahre die Stromerzeuger sogar 50
Milliarden Geld das den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern jeden Tag aus der Tasche gezogen
wird andere Länder haben dieses
Marktversagen längst mit preisdeckeln
oder wenigstens mit übergewinn Steuern
darauf reagiert frankreich hat den
Anstieg des Strompreises auf vier
Prozent begrenzt da sind sie nicht erst
nach Brüssel gefahren und haben lange
Verhandlungen geführt ein Liter Sprit
kostet rund 40 Cent in Frankreich
weniger als bei uns und der Beitrag des
hochkompetenten deutschen
Wirtschaftsministers zu Energiekrise er
lässt sich von den
energielobbyisten ein Gesetz zu einer
gasumlage schreiben dass die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger die Familien und Unternehmen
die sowieso schon leiden zusätzlich zur
Kasse bitten wird also da muss man
wirklich sagen auf so ein Einfall muss
man erstmal kommen wir haben wirklich
die dümmste Regierung in Europa wenn man
sich das anguckt
nicht nur aber nicht nur weil sie zu
Feige sind sich mit den Krisen Gewinnern
anzulegen das größte Problem das größte
Problem ist ihre grandiose Idee einen
beispiellosen Wirtschaftskrieg gegen
unseren wichtigsten Energielieferanten
vom Zaun zu brechen ja natürlich ist der
genau Verbrechen aber die Vorstellung
die Vorstellung dass wir Putin dadurch
bestrafen dass wir Millionen Familien in
Deutschland in die Armut stürzen und
dass wir unsere Industrie zerstören
während
gastron-rekordgewinne macht ja wie
bescheuert ist das denn
preiswerte Energie ist die wichtigste
Existenzbedingung unserer Industrie
und wo haben Sie denn Ersatz aufgetan
habe bei amerikanischen Fracking das
Anbietern die aktuell 200 Millionen Euro
gewinnen mit jedem einzelnen Tanker
machen klar so kann man die gassprecher
auch füllen aber den Ruinen von Familien
und Mittelständlern die diese Mondpreise
am Ende bezahlen müssen den werden sie
damit nicht aufhalten und es fängt doch
schon an ich meine dass der Gaspreis
dass der Gasverbrauch der Industrie
umfasst ein fünfte eingebrochen ist das
liegt doch nicht an plötzlichen
Effizienz gewinnen das liegt doch daran
dass die Produktion schon jetzt
dramatisch zurückgeht und bevorzugtes
Ziel von Produktionsverlagerungen ist
übrigens neuerdings wieder die USA weil
der Gaspreis in Deutschland inzwischen
acht Mal so hoch ist wie in Übersee make
America great again tolle Strategie für
eine deutsche Regierung
der Hauptgeschäftsführer des DRK geht
davon aus dass Deutschland bei
Fortsetzung der jetzigen Strategie in
wenigen Jahren 20 bis 30 Prozent
ärmer sein wird ja ob es uns gefällt
oder nicht wenn wir ein Industrieland
bleiben wollen dann brauchen wir
russische Rohstoffe und leider auf
absehbare Zeit auch noch russische
Energie und deshalb schluss mit den
fatalen Wirtschaftssanktionen verhandeln
wir in Russland mit Russland über eine
Wiederaufnahme der Gaslieferung wir sind
nicht unabhängig wie machen sich doch
uns und uns etwas vor und lieber Herr
Habeck es mag ja sein dass ihnen auch
egal ist was ihre deutschen Wähler
denken aber sie haben nicht das Recht
Millionen Menschen die sie mehrheitlich
nicht gewählt haben ihren bescheidenen
Wohlstand und ihre Zukunft zu zerstören
und deshalb treten sie zurück denn ihre
Laufzeit Verlängerung die führt mit
Sicherheit zum Super-GAU der deutschen
Wirtschaft dankeschön
mit einer Rücktrittsforderung an
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck endet
die Rede von Sahra Wagenknecht aus der
Linksfraktion die sich deutschlandführer
in Wirtschaftskrieg gegen Zitat unseren
wichtigsten Energielieferanten diese
Perspektive hat sie hier im Plenum
einigermaßen exklusiv Felix bannaschak
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Sahra Wagenknecht in dieser Rede reden
lassen wollen ich sag mein aller
Verbundenheit dass man eine dumme Idee
eine richtig richtig schlechte Idee
Herr Spahn
ersparen sie haben gerade
sechs Monate mit 16 Jahren verglichen
und ich übersetze das meine gleiche
Einheit 192 Monate hat die
unionsgeführte Regierung alles dafür
getan den Ausbau der Erneuerbaren zu
verschleppen den Ausbau der Stromnetzen
insbesondere bei ihnen in Bayern Herr
Dobrindt 192 verlorene Monate und das
bis heute fünf Minuten hatten sie zur
Verfügung kein Wort zum Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren kein Wort zum Ausbau der
Stromnetze für die versorgungssicherung
das ist ihre Politik und
Nordrhein-Westfalen in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen haben die
stundenlang diskutiert weil sie jedes
Windkraftwerk verhindern wollten weil
sie jedes Solarpanel verhindern wollten
mit Rücksicht auf die Wahlkreise ich
habe folgende these meine Damen und
Herren wenn in dieser Debatte nur noch
Menschen reden zum Thema Atom die bereit
sind in ihrem Wahlkreis ergebnisoffen
nach einem nuklearen Endlager zu suchen
ist diese Debatte in fünf Minuten zu
Ende Herr banatschak
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage von
Herrn Ernst aus der Fraktion DIE LINKE
sie haben das Wort
herzlichen Dank dass Sie die Frage
zulassen
das erste Bemerkung ich komme ich konnte
nicht drumrum in dem Moment wo man hier
den Versuch unternimmt das zu tun was er
habe gesagt nämlich uns drum zu kümmern
dass er mehr Energie her kriegen dass
man tatsächlich mehr gasher kriegen dass
wir ölen Sie das ist Interesse Putins
die sind Putin Leute also diese Form der
Auseinandersetzung tut mir leid diese
Form der Auseinandersetzung ich weiß
nicht ob das hier Stil ist ich finde
diese diesem Hause eigentlich
unangemessen und nun die zweite Frage
die zweite Frage ist wir haben nun
mehrfach erlebt dass Vertreter der
Koalition darauf hinweisen dass 16 Jahre
in der falsche Politik betrieben worden
ist das wissen wir inzwischen aber auch
sie haben so oft genug gesagt was sie
aber schuldig bleiben ist wie sie denn
die gegenwärtige Krise nun eigentlich
wirklich bewältigen wollen wir wissen
wir
da könnt ihr euch aufregen wie ihr wollt
ich habe den Eindruck über Ankündigungen
wir wollen wir werden kommen doch
überhaupt nicht hinaus wir haben bis
jetzt keine Lösung zum Beispiel für
Schwedt sie haben keine Lösung für das
was uns im Winter blüht sie haben keine
Lösung wie wir genug Energie herkriegen
und im selben Moment im selben Moment
lehnen sie aber eine Möglichkeit ab wo
er auch nicht wissen wie sie endet aber
man kann doch zum Mittel miteinander
reden und fragen wir kriegen wir denn
mehr Gas her und mehr Öl das könnte man
doch mal machen und wenn Sie das
Ablehnen dann kann ich sagen dann stimmt
natürlich das dass sie den andere wissen
als wie die die Bürger und die Industrie
in diesem Lande haben wichtiger sind als
das was sie eigentlich wirklich machen
das ist wirklich ein Problem
Herr ernst
der Herr Ernst ich habe zwar bei dem was
Sie gesagt haben das Fragezeichen nicht
gehört aber ich will trotzdem gern
antworten das spricht ja Bände für ihre
Fraktion es spricht der Bänder für ihre
Fraktion auch Herr Dr Bartsch dass sie
dazu klatschen das ausgerechnet die
beiden hier sprechen Sahra Wagenknecht
und Klaus Ernst die entgegen der
Fraktionslinie muss man ja sagen die
Öffnung von 192 fordern und damit das
zentrale sanktionsargument gegen den
Kriegsverbrecher Wladimir Putin außer
Kraft setzen wollen und dass sie
und das seht ihr diese Täter opferumkehr
betreiben und Wladimir Putin und
Russland quasi zum angriffsopfer eines
westlichen Wirtschaftskrieges
zelisieren wollen obwohl Wladimir Putin
nicht nur den Krieg in die Ukraine
sondern gegen Deutschland gegen Europa
und gegen den Rest der Welt führt mit
Energie mit hungerskrisen und so viel
mehr das ist beschämend und das sagt
alles zu dem was sie in dieser Debatte
zu sagen haben
kommen wir
kommen wir zurück zur Union Herr Merz
ist jetzt
Herr Merz ist leider nicht mehr da hat
bestimmt andere Termine Herr März hat ja
völlig richtig schon im Juli gesagt wir
müssen uns auf Wohlstandsverluste
einstellen wenn wir Frieden und Freiheit
gegen unter anderem das was dort gesagt
wurde Verteidiger völlig richtig aber
Herr Merz bleibt leider die zwei
zentralen Antworten schuldig die sich
aus dieser Analyse ergeben nämlich wie
wollen wir diesen Wohlstandsverlust
sozialgerecht verteilen das ist die
sozialpolitische Frage die wir mit
diesem Entlastungspaket seit dem
Wochenende angehen und die zweite die
zweite und dies mindestens genauso
wichtig dass die ökonomische Frage wie
wir diesen Wohlstandsverlust begrenzen
wollen und diese Bundesregierung will
und sie wird den Wohlstandsverlust
begrenzen trotz enorme Herausforderungen
und das hat Robert habe gerade
überzeugend dargestellt
wir haben in dieser debatsche schon am
Dienstag viel über Inflation gehört
unbestritten eine große Gefahr aber die
zweite große Gefahr die laut das ist
doch eine Rezession eine Rezession mit
Abschwung mit Arbeitslosigkeit und mit
Bedrohung für ganze Wirtschaftsbranchen
und deswegen ist es richtig dass die
unternehmenshilfen ausgeweitet werden
dass das Energiekosten dämpfungsprogramm
für kleine und für mittlere Unternehmen
ausgeweitet wird dass wir den Spitzen
Ausgleich bei Strom und Energie
verlängern und damit 9000 Unternehmen
stabilisieren das ist die kurzfristige
Antwort auf die Wirtschaft und
energiepolitischen Herausforderungen die
sich hier stellen herr Scholz hat
gestern gesagt wir lösen die Probleme
über vor andere sie direkt erkannt haben
da wäre ich ein bisschen vorsichtig aber
wir haben sie immerhin erkannt wir gehen
Sie an und Sie können leider nur dagegen
opponieren ohne einen eigenen Vorschlag
zu haben dass es ziemlich bedauerlich
aber meine Damen und Herren hinter den
kurzfristigen Herausforderungen vor
denen wir stehen stehenden noch viel
größere und deswegen ist es wichtig bei
allem was wir tun um beispielsweise
lng-terminals jetzt schneller ans Netz
zu bringen neue fossile Infrastrukturen
ja zu schaffen dass wir gleichzeitig den
Blick für die Zukunft nicht verlieren
dass wir die großen
transformationsherausforderungen vor
denen wir sowieso schon stehen und die
jetzt ja nicht kleiner geworden sind
intensiv angehen Ausbau der Erneuerbaren
Ausbau der elektrolysekapazitäten damit
wir bald grünen Wasserstoff zur
Verfügung haben damit an der
direktreduktionsanlage von arsenormittal
in Hamburg die jetzt wegen der hohen
Produktionskosten vom Netz gehen wird
vielleicht bald schon CO2-neutral Stahl
produziert werden kann in diesem
Haushalt und im
klima-betrag für Energieeffizienz
vorgesehen ein Rekordbetrag für den
Ausbau einer klimaneutralen
wasserstoffinfrastruktur ein
Rekordbetrag beispielsweise auch für das
zentrale Innovationsprogramm Mittelstand
alles was sie immer gefordert und selbst
die umgesetzt haben das ist die Politik
dieser Regierung nur kurzfristig die
notlindern langfristig die
Herausforderung angehen vielen Dank
felix wanderscheck war das aus der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen nächster
Redner in dieser sehr munteren Debatte
ist Andreas Jung da kommt das der
Unionsfraktion und ist dort Sprecher für
Klimaschutz und Energie
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Herr Minister sie haben in
ihrer Rede im kritischen Blick zurück
angemahnt dazu will ich eine Bemerkung
machen wir haben in der
corona-pandemie eine Lehre aus
vorangegangenen Krisen gezogen und diese
Lehre war in der Krisenbewältigung darf
nie wieder der Klimaschutz hinten
angestellt werden nie wieder dafür zu
sein dass wir über die Bewältigung der
einen Krise die andere Krise die
Klimakrise aus dem Blick verliert und
deshalb haben wir gleichzeitig in
Stabilisierung und Entlastung in Zukunft
Technologien in Klimaschutz investiert
wir haben alles zusammengebracht und das
ist unsere Erwartung an sie und das ist
unser Befund das ist in dieser Krise
eben nicht gemacht wird sie stellen den
Klimaschutz in dieser Krise hinten an
bei der Energiesicherheit sind wir nicht
so weit wie sie und Olaf Scholz gestern
darstellen wollten es ist nicht geritzt
dass wir über den Winter kommen die
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber haben es am
Montag doch klar aufgeschrieben ist
droht weiterhin eine Notlage und deshalb
müssen alle Kapazitäten genutzt werden
das heißt da muss mehr gemacht werden
bei den Entlastungen ist es unkonkret
sie haben jetzt wieder Ankündigung
gemacht obwohl sie doch den ganzen
Sommer darüber verhandelt haben wie
Normalverdiener die jetzt hart getroffen
sind besser unterstützt werden können
wie Betriebe unterstützt werden können
die Industrie Russland Russwurm war bei
ihrer Klausurtagung hat gesagt es geht
um die Substanz der Industrie sie haben
darauf keine Antwort bisher die
Bäckereien der Mittelstand alle weisen
darauf hin wie hart Sie getroffen sind
da gibt es Ankündigung aber nach
wochenlangen Beratung keine Antwort es
soll jetzt ein Expertengremium
eingesetzt werden das ist zu wenig es
ist zu langsam es muss konsequenter sein
und bei all dem wird der Klimaschutz
hinten angestellt und ich will es
konkret am Beispiel machen
Stresstest sie haben bei dem Stresstest
prüfen lassen auf Netzstabilität aber
sie haben nicht prüfen lassen auf die
Stabilität der Ökosysteme sie haben
nicht die Frage gestellt ob befristet
etwas länger Kernenergie weniger Kohle
damit weniger CO2 bedeuten könnte diese
Prüfung diese Frage liegt aber auf der
Hand sie ist aber kein Maßstab in ihrer
Prüfung deshalb setzen sie einseitig auf
die Kohle sie setzen einseitig auf das
Öl und deshalb fällt es auf Sie zurück
wenn Sie sagen
alles tun um aus dem fossilen Energien
auszugehen das tun sie gerade nicht und
es wird deutlich bei der Bioenergie wir
haben hier im Deutschen Bundestag
beantragt den Deckel bei der Bioenergie
wegzumachen da könnte jetzt kurzfristig
nicht erst langfristig kurzfristig
könnten Potenziale genutzt werden das
meist liegt in den Lagern es könnte
jetzt mehr Strom mehr Wärme Biomethan
produziert werden im Stresstest von
Montag schreiben Sie auf die Situation
im nächsten Winter dieser eine andere
aus einigen Gründen und ganz wichtiger
Grund sei dann würde er mehr Strom aus
Biogas als Bioenergie zur Verfügung
stehen im nächsten Winter werden sie
unserem Antrag gefolgt wird in diesem
Winter zur Verfügung stehen deshalb wenn
sie sagen verbockt und verhindert es
fällt auf sie zurück das haben sie
verbockt deshalb sie verhindert wir
könnten in diesem Winter mehr Bioenergie
nutzen stattdessen sich erst ignoriert
dann abgelehnt und jetzt verbummelt sie
haben im Juli dann angekündigt sehen wir
uns doch so machen wie wir das beantragt
haben im Juli es gibt auch immer noch
kein Kabinettsbeschluss immer noch kein
kabinettsverschluss den wollen sie jetzt
im September machen das richtig dass es
jetzt machen aber es zu spät es ist
verbummelt es hätte mehr getan werden
müssen und es zeigt es wird im
Klimaschutz und Energiesicherheit nicht
zusammengedacht und ich will es ganz
konkret machen am Klimaschutzgesetz auch
das was war eine Lehre es war die Lehre
aus dem Jahr 2019 dass die Klimaziele
nicht ausreichend verbindlich Waren
werden nach langer Diskussion
Umweltpolitiker vieler Fraktionen lange
wir haben lange dafür gekämpft und wir
haben es lieber Matthias Mirsch 2019
erreicht und du hast im Deutschen
Bundestag gesagt wir werden es nie
wieder eine Minister durchgehen lassen
dass der Klimaziele nicht erreicht und
das tun sie jetzt sie haben sie haben
die gesetzliche Verpflichtung das ist
kein grüner Parteitagsbeschluss es ist
nicht das Wahlplakat eines selbst
ernannten klimakanz das ist eine
gesetzliche Verpflichtung aus dem
Klimaschutzgesetz zum 30 Juni diesen
Jahres ein Sofortprogramm vorzulegen zu
schließen der klimaki sie haben nichts
gemacht ihre Experten haben die
Vorschläge aus dem Verkehrsministerium
zerrissen die haben den sogar die
Ernsthaftigkeit abgesprochen es gibt
keinen Vorschlag des widerspricht der
gesetzlichen Pflicht und es hat ja ein
Sinn des zum 30 Juni gemacht werden
sollte das nachgesteuert werden können
das Sofortmaßnahmen auf den Weg gebracht
werden können und stattdessen wollen sie
das Klimaschutzgesetz das ihre Partei
als zu Lacks kritisiert hat aufweichen
sie wollen weg davon dass im Jahre
schreiben und Sektoren des vorgelegt
werden muss das war aber gerade die
Lehre gegen verstoßen sie jetzt und
deshalb muss man sagen sie müssen mehr
tun für Energiesicherheit mehr tun für
Entlastung und mehr tun für Klimaschutz
sie müssen zusammenbringen das ist
unsere Erwartung herzlichen Dank
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion
Frank junge
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
lassen Sie mich vielleicht zunächst
einmal sagen Putins verbrecherische
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine ist
gleichzeitig auch ein von ihm bewusst
und von Anfang an kalkulierter
Nahrungsmittel und energiekrieg gegen
Europa und die Welt und Frau Wagenknecht
es ist erschütternd es ist erschüttern
Sie heute hier mit diesen Aussagen zu
hören sie könnten faktisch drüben Platz
nehmen das ist uni so eine genau das
gleiche was die AFD hier auch verlauten
lässt
die die verheerenden Folgen dieser
Situation ist hier in voller Breite aus
vorgetragen worden und ich denke und das
ist auch noch mal ein Punkt den man ja
ganz klar herausstellen muss das was
diese Regierungskoalition auch mit
diesem Wirtschaftsminister und dem
gesamten Haus in den zurückliegenden
Monaten auf die Beine gestellt hat das
ist bemerkenswert davon muss man den Hut
ziehen wir wären mit anderen
Wirtschaftsministern untergegangen wir
haben die Wirtschaft an der Stelle am
Laufen gehalten die Energiesicherheit
sichergestellt und das ist eine
Situation die kann man nicht so
diskreditieren wie das hier gerade
vorgefallen ist
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen vor genau
diesem Hintergrund halte ich es für ja
für hanebüchen und für für Gaukelei wenn
Ihre Vorschläge Herr Merz aus ihrer aus
ihrer Fraktion darauf abheben dass sie
dass sie den Leuten scheinbar einfache
Lösungen sozusagen offerieren die aber
entweder gar nicht umsetzbar sind oder
aber am Ende noch viel viel teurer
werden als das was gegenwärtig zu
bewältigen ist der Punkt Atomenergie ist
ja hier schon angesprochen worden und
von dem Hintergrund ist das aus meiner
Sicht reiner Populismus den man hier
auch als solchen benennen muss liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ein Punkt noch
während sie mit ihren scheinbaren
Vorschlägen oder gar kein konstruktiven
Beiträgen versuchen in der
Öffentlichkeit zu punkten mit markigen
Worten hat diese Regierungskoalition
drei entlastungspakete auf den Weg
gebracht die nicht nur dazu beitragen
die soziale Sicherheit und auch die
Solidarität ein Stück weit zu
unterstützen die auch gerade Unternehmen
im kleinen und mittelständischen Bereich
jetzt schon unterlassen entlasten von
dem Hintergrund ist es aber für uns alle
eine Selbstverständlichkeit dass wir mit
diesem Maßnahmen nicht eben aufhören
sondern jetzt schon daran denken wie
geht es weiter die Fragen Strom macht
die seien angehen die Frage wie kriegen
wir eine vernünftige gaspreisbremse hin
sind ja hier schon erwähnt worden und
genau das müssen die zur Kenntnis nehmen
bevor sie hier in diesem Bausch und
Bogen uns kritisieren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ich komme noch mal ganz
kurz auf den Haushalt selbst des bmwk zu
sprechen natürlich und das unterstreiche
ich auch ausdrücklich der Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien bringt uns neben
der Frage der Krisenbewältigung in eine
Situation wo wir unsere Wirtschaft
insgesamt Krisen resilienter machen wo
wir dazu beitragen Sie unabhängig von
solchen Preisentwicklungen in
Energiesektor zu machen wie die die wir
gerade erleben und hier gestatte ich mir
auch noch mal den Hinweis dass wir jetzt
auch beim Ausbau der Stromnetze das
Ausmerzen müssen
Stichwort März was sie im Rahmen ihrer
bisherigen Politik mit verhindert haben
wenn wir also jetzt schon vernünftige
Stromnetze hätten könnten wir auch ganz
anders andere Bundesländer mit Ökostrom
versorgen das ist ein Versäumnis wo wir
jetzt gerade stehen müssen dafür aber es
auch anpacken werden und noch ein Punkt
will ich erwähnen es geht nämlich darum
dass wir mit diesem Haushalt nicht nur
die energietransformation die
Transformation der Wirtschaft die
Investitionen in Wasserstofftechnologie
in E-Mobilität in Energie Wärme und
mobilitätswende vornehmen es geht ja
auch darum in althergebrachter Form
klein und mittelständische Unternehmen
zu unterstützen und hier will ich ein
Beispiel nennen das wurde hier schon
ganz kurz erwähnt wir investieren damit
nämlich auch in die Fragen wie wir
Innovationsförderung aber auch Forschung
und Entwicklung weiter voranbringen
können und das ist eine Situation die
gerade diesen Unternehmen in
Größenordnungen zugute kommt und wenn
ich hier im Entwurf sehe das schon von
vornherein 80 Millionen Euro mehr drin
stecken und wir ein zentralen
Innovationsprogramm Mittelstand schon
auf 700 Millionen Euro
Investitionsmöglichkeiten kommen ist das
eine gute Entwicklung die man gerade für
diese Unternehmen hervorheben muss liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen lassen sie mich
zum Schluss sagen dass ich natürlich
auch an diesem Haushaltsentwurf
Verbesserungsbedarf sehe vor allen
Dingen dann wenn es um die Frage geht
die Gemeinschaftsaufgabe regionale
Wirtschaftsstruktur in Angriff zu nehmen
wenn wir die Frage diskutieren wie wir
schwächere wirtschaftliche Regionen
unterstützen können dann bietet genau
diese Kulisse hervorragende
Möglichkeiten und vor dem Hintergrund
ist der Haushaltsansatz für mich völlig
unzufriedenstellend das werden wir im
parlamentarischen Verfahren Regeln ich
lade sie alle zu konstruktiver Mitarbeit
ein vielen Dank
Frank Junge ist für die SPD im
Haushaltsausschuss und dasselbe gilt die
Mitgliedschaft im Haushaltsausschuss
jedenfalls für Wolfgang Wieler
fraktions- und parteizugehörig ist er
der AFD
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen bis vor kurzem
ist das Wirtschaftsministerium
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Energie der zweite Begriff Energie
musste dem Klimaschutz weichen das ist
bezeichnend dafür wie wenig eine sichere
Energieversorgung dieser Regierung noch
wert ist
[Applaus]
anscheinend hat niemand analysiert wir
verletzlich unser Land die Bürger und
die Wirtschaft sind bevor man die
sanktionsspirale gegen Russland
losgetreten hat
und anscheinend hat auch niemand
analysiert was der gleichzeitige
Ausstieg aus Kohle und Kernkraft für die
Stromversorgung bedeutet wenn Wind und
Sonne nicht liefern dann hängt das Land
nun in fataler Weise von Gaskraftwerken
ab diese Politik ist ein völliger
Fehlschlag nur die Regierung will es
nicht zugeben
[Applaus]
jetzt reaktivieren Sie Herr Minister
Habeck sogar Kohlekraftwerke um den
großen Blackout vielleicht noch
abzuwenden ihre politischen Freunde von
Greenpeace
sagen heute schon öffentlich welchen
Preis das in der grünen Weltsicht hat
das zusätzliche CO2 aus der Kohle müsste
künftig wieder eingespart werden im
zusätzlichen Kohlestrom von heute
steckten nach dieser Logik also schon
die heizbeschränkungen die Fahrverbote
und ihr Betriebsschließungen von morgen
gerade mal eine Milliarde haben Sie
zusätzlich zur Stützung
energieintensiver Unternehmen damit Herr
Minister werden sie die
Deindustrialisierung Deutschlands nicht
verhindern an die Ursachen müssen wir
heran
[Applaus]
und im Mittelpunkt der Krise steht die
gescheiterte Energiewende obwohl die
Kernenergie dringend gebraucht wird und
noch dazu CO2-neutrales halten sie am
Atomausstieg halsstarrig fest und der
Kollege Partnerschaft hat das noch mal
bestellt
zwei Kraftwerke für ein paar Monate in
Bereitschaft zu halten produziert keine
einzige Kilowattstunde und senkt den
Strompreis nicht um einen Zehntel Cent
so wird Deutschland mit dieser Regierung
zum Gefangenen der Ideologie grüner
Minister und der Grünen Partei die
Zukunft dieses Landes der Bestand
zahllose Unternehmen
hunderttausende Arbeitsplätze und die
Existenz genauso vieler Familien stehen
auf dem Spiel
[Applaus]
eine solche Partei meine Damen und
Herren ist absolut
regierungsunfähig mit diesen grünen darf
es keine Koalitionen mehr geben das sage
ich hier nicht nur den Kollegen von SPD
und FDP sondern auch von der Union denn
fast die Hälfte der Bundesbürger lebt in
Ländern mit schwarz-grünen Koalitionen
eines solche Partei die ihre Ideologie
ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste über die
Interessen unseres Landes stellt gehört
abgewählt und zwar für Jahrzehnte
Wolfgang Wiehle aus der
afd-fraktion und hier geht es weiter mit
einem der profiliertesten oder
kenntnisreichsten
Umweltschutz und Klima
umwelt-fraktion Lukas Köhler inzwischen
auch stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender
meine sehr verehrte Präsident meine
lieben Damen und Herren keine Sorge wir
bleiben oben die Menschen haben sorgen
die Menschen haben sorgen in diesem Land
die Unternehmen haben Sorgen und für
viele ist diese Situation dramatisch und
wir stellen uns hier hin und
ehrlicherweise was wir in dieser Debatte
bisher geführt haben überrascht mich
doch sehr wir streiten uns darüber wer
Verantwortung für irgendwas übernimmt
und wir streiten uns darüber wer
Verantwortung übernehmen soll verstehen
Sie mich nicht falsch ich glaube es ist
absolut richtig und es ist wichtig dass
wir eine starke Opposition brauchen die
Stärke sollte aber nicht in rhetorisch
geschwungenen geschliffenen Worten über
Robert Habeck kommen sondern in der
Sache die Vorschläge müssen da sein und
wir müssen darüber diskutieren und
debattieren was wir verändern wollen um
dieses Land nach vorne zu bringen die
Leute wollen Streit in der Sache und wir
als
regierungstragende Fraktionen wir
liefern wir liefern eine Menge an Dingen
die dafür sorgen werden dass den
Menschen in Deutschland und den
Unternehmen in Deutschland besser gehen
und das ist richtig so es ist richtig so
dass wir darüber diskutieren wie wir es
hinbekommen und dass wir das geschafft
haben die Gasspeicher zu füllen meine
Damen und Herren es waren Kraftakt und
es ist ein Kraftakt dass wir bei 780%
sind und es sichert in Deutschland
weiter die Produktion und das Heizen ab
und es ist richtig dass wir in
mittlerweile drei entlastungspaketen den
Menschen da helfen wo es schwer für sie
ist den Menschen die wenig Geld haben
die Menschen die wenig Möglichkeiten
haben die hohen Kosten noch zu tragen
dass wir die entlasten ist völlig
richtig und das setzen wir als Regierung
konsequent um und ich finde darüber
können wir uns unterhalten da können sie
sagen das sind gute oder schlechte Ideen
wir können auch darüber streiten was für
eine Art von Wirtschaftspolitik wir
jetzt brauchen und ich glaube in einer
Inflation ist es absolut klar dass wir
eine angebotsorientierte
Wirtschaftspolitik brauchen wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass Produktivität
gesteigert wird wir müssen auch darüber
nachdenken dass es ein nach der Krise
geben wird und das bedeutet dass dann
die Wirtschaft auch wieder wachsen muss
dass dann gute Jobs geschaffen werden
müssen das ist dann weitergehen muss und
weiter aufwärts gehen muss mit diesem
Land und das bedeutet dass wir jetzt in
die notwendige
Bürokratieabbau in den notwendigen
Bürokratieabbau investieren müssen dass
wir jetzt als Regierung dafür sorgen
müssen dass Dinge einfacher werden und
das machen wir das machen wir täglich
das machen wir wenn wir dafür sorgen
dass die Menschen bei den Solaranlagen
einfacher Ihre Geld verdienen können
dass sie nicht mehr so viele Hürden
haben das machen wir wenn wir über die
ganze Bürokratieabbau in den
Planungsprozessen sprechen das machen
wir mit einem LNG Beschleunigungsgesetz
das in einer Zeit vorgelegt wurde die
unvergleichlich ist und die dafür sorgt
dass wir in enormster Geschwindigkeit
Ding ans Netz bringen und das machen wir
auch wenn wir darüber diskutieren und
streiten wie wir in Zukunft unsere
Energieversorgung ausrichten und dazu
brauchen wir die erneuerbaren Energien
und zwar in riesigen Maß aber wir
brauchen auch über den Winter und über
den Winter zu kommen jede einzelne
Produktionskapazität die wir haben und
deswegen sind wir im Moment noch in der
Diskussion darüber wie das mit der
Atomenergie weitergeht wir sind der
Meinung dass wir auch die drei im
Weiterbetrieb brauchen
[Applaus]
nächste Rednerin für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen Claudia Müller
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lieber Dietmar Bartsch ich muss
doch einmal ganz kurz meinen
Enttäuschung ausdrücken
dass du die einzige Redezeit eurer
Fraktion hergegeben hast für eine Täter
opferumkehr für populistische und
falsche Argumente und nicht für Lösungen
sondern für den das Wort reden eines
Kriegsverbrechers ganz ehrlich das ist
auch eure Fraktion nicht würdig
wir sehen
an der Transformation der Wirtschaft und
unsere Energieversorgung führt kein Weg
vorbei das gilt an Land wie auf See
Resilienz unserer Versorgungssysteme
geht nur mit einer starken
klimaneutralen Schifffahrt um mit
zukunftsfähigen Häfen wie zum Beispiel
in meiner Heimatstadt Rostock und
deswegen bin ich Robert Habeck und
seinem Haus sehr dankbar dass im
maritimbereich trotz der schwierigen
Haushaltslage vieles vorangebracht wird
aktuell findet in Hamburg die weltgrößte
Messe der Maritim Industriestadt die SMM
die Fragen die dort diskutiert werden
sind die grundsätzlichen
Wirtschaftsfragen die wir uns alle
stellen Energie Transformation
Sicherheit von Lieferketten Resilienz
und die maritime Welt spielt eine
entscheidende Rolle bei unserer
Versorgungssicherheit denn wir im und
exportieren in erster Linie per Schiff
Entschuldigung gestatten sie eine
Zwischenfrage aus der afd-fraktion
und für die jetzt anstehenden Fragen der
kurzfristigen Energiesicherheit spielt
ebenfalls die Schiff an einer
entscheidende Rolle Stichwort LNG fsius
und auch lang und mittelfristig für den
Import von Wasserstoff und entsprechend
Derivaten ist die Schifffahrt und die
Häfen entscheiden und dabei werden wir
jetzt nicht vergessen wer jetzt für
andere Verantwortung übernimmt wie zum
Beispiel Rostock und Schwedisch
angesprochen wird worden für die
rohölversorgung für die Raffinerien
Schwedt das wird später bei
Investitionen beim Thema Wasserstoff
berücksichtigt werden und zweitens
natürlich auch beim Thema
offshoreenergie es spielt der
maritime-bereich eine entscheidende
Rolle denn es sind eben nicht nur die
Windkraftanlagen es sind Konverter
Stationen es ist die Kabelverlegung es
sind die jack-up check-up-schiffe und
natürlich auch hinterher der Service der
für die Sicherheit sorgt wir sehen
Energiepolitik und Wirtschaft und
Industriepolitik sind eng miteinander
verzahnt und im maritimenbereich für
fallen die Frage der Energieproduktion
im und exportstrukturen und die Nutzung
zusammen deshalb ist die Unterstützung
für Projekte wie dem klimaneutralen
Schiff
Maritim Innovationsprogramm und der
innovationshilfen Werft sowie der
Forschung und Bereich der Entwicklung
maritime energiensysteme so wichtig und
deshalb
ist die maritime
infrastruktursystemrelevant wir werden
hier unsere Unterstützung weiterhin
Stärken stark halten und das tun wir mit
diesem Haushalt
Claudia Müller ist eine der
Koordinatorinnen für bestimmte
Aufgabenbereiche durch der
Bundesregierung in diesem Fall für
maritime Wirtschaft und in dieser Rolle
hat sie hier natürlich auch gesprochen
in der Debatte über den Etat des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers jetzt die
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecherin der
Fraktion cdu/csu Julia Klöckner
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Herr
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen eines vorab ich
war mehr als irritierten jetzt beziehe
ich mich nicht auf irgendeine Sendung
sondern auf ihren Auftritt hier Herr
Bundeswirtschaftsminister sie haben
einen merkwürdiges Demokratieverständnis
des die Opposition sie nicht beim
Regieren irgendwie stören soll ich kann
Ihnen sagen es ist gut dass wir sie mal
beim Denken gestört haben denn sie
hatten vergessen dass die Mehrwertsteuer
auf die gasumlage zum Beispiel noch
drauf kommt und wenn wir uns noch mal
anschauen
sie holen Zahlen raus werfen der Union
vor wir hätten jahrelang den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien speziell in Bayern
blockiert also wenn wir uns mal die
Tabellen richtig anschauen herr
Kretschmann grün aus Baden-Württemberg
hat jahrelang den Tabellenkeller
angeführt beim Windkraftausbau auch das
gehört am Ende
[Applaus]
der Welt ich verstehe dass sie unter
Druck sind und ich finde auch dass man
auch Verständnis haben muss dass eine
Regierung die im krisenmodus ist auch
Fehler macht aber was ich nicht
akzeptieren kann ist es hier geholzt
wird gegen eine Opposition die mit ganz
konkreten Vorschlägen hier in die
Diskussion geht und sich von ganz rechts
und ganz links abgrenzt weil wir wissen
was es heißt für dieses Land auch
Verantwortung zu übernehmen und dann
komme ich zur Wirtschaft und sie haben
heute in ihrer Rede die Wirtschaft die
Mittelständler die Industrie die Lage
wie sie ist noch nicht mal annähernd mit
einer Empathie versehen dass man sich
hoffen kann dass sie wirklich in ganz
konkretes arbeiten kommen um es konkret
zu machen
das Leibniz-Institut für
Wirtschaftsforschung in Halle hat es
beziffert wir haben eine
insolvenzzahl oder Steigerung wir haben
26 Prozent mehr Insolvenzen im Vergleich
zu 2021 im Herbst wird es ansteigen ich
muss die Namen nicht alle nennen das
sind aber alles Arbeitsplätze das sind
Steuereinnahmen das ist
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland und am
Ende ist Ihre Antwort einfach nur das
dritte entlastungs-
die Wirtschaft ich habe manchmal den
Eindruck die Deindustrialisierung kommt
in grünen gerade recht damit sie ihre
co2-klimaziele erreichen aber
wirtschaftlicher Wachstum
Wohlstand sind doch kein Selbstläufer
denken Sie doch mal an die
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer die
dieses Land zusammen mit ihren
Mitarbeitern am Laufen halten und dann
gehen wir doch mal rein in ihr Programm
da sagen sie sie wollen ein Programm für
energieintensive Unternehmen auflegen
die Steigerung Ihrer Energiekosten nicht
weitergeben können jetzt sagen sie gibt
es schon moment mal sie haben im
Entlastungspaket geschrieben sie wollen
eins auflegen wir schauen uns das Ganze
an hören aus der Ministerium es muss
nachgebessert werden und wir alle wissen
bisher hat dieses Programm gar nichts
gebracht bei ihnen
Entschuldigung wollte in den Redefluss
nicht unterbrechen ich habe die Zeit
angehalten gestatten Sie eine Frage aus
der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen von
Herrn banatschak Frage oder
Zwischenbemerkung
in der Zeit wenn er seine Sachen nicht
untergekriegt hat falsch verstanden
worden ist wie das öfter bei grünen ja
ist dann denke ich ist seine Zeit
gewesen zweiter Punkt das Energiekosten
dämpfungsprogramm soll für weitere
Unternehmen geöffnet werden die nicht
auf der kübelliste stehen ja wann kommen
denn diese Anpassung und für wen was
sagt die Europäische Kommission sind
alles Ankündigungen und dann sagen sie
noch unternehmen sollen bei
Investitionen Effizienz und
substitutionsmaßnahmen unterstützt
werden ja und was heißt das also sie
alle sagen auch von der FDP wir sind
noch in der Diskussion solche Ihnen was
sagen während sie in der Diskussion sind
gehen bei den Unternehmerinnen und
Unternehmern die Lichter aus und
Menschen verlieren ihre Arbeit wir haben
doch keine Zeit hier ständig noch in
Diskussion zu sein und deshalb bin ich
mehr als erstaunt über diesen Haushalt
den sie vorlegen sie kürzen die Mittel
für digitale Technologien die Mittel für
innovative Unternehmensgründungen sie
kürzen die Mittel für berufliche Bildung
Mittelstand Fortbildungseinrichtung ich
kann nur sagen wir brauchen einen
Wirtschaftsminister und keinen
Insolvenzverwalter in dieser
Bundesregierung
Julia Klöckner aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
wo sie wirtschaftspolitische Sprecherin
ist und wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher
ist auch Bernd Westphal allerdings kommt
er aus der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
wir sind in einer sehr schwierigen
Situation ohne Frage und alle
beschäftigt das sehr nicht nur hier uns
im Bundestag sondern auch die
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer die
Menschen in unserem Land aber ich sage
Ihnen diese Reden die wir hier heute von
ganz links und ganz rechts in diesem
Haus gehört haben die angstschüren da
will ich nur sagen Angst muss in diesem
Land keiner haben diese Politik sorgt
dafür für gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt für soziale Entlastung wir
nehmen das ernst was hier diese
Situation vorträgt
diese ampelregierung noch nicht ein Jahr
im Amt hat mit wahrlich schweren Themen
zu tun und deshalb muss man das
honorieren was sie auf den Weg gebracht
worden ist das dritte Entlastungspaket
was neben kaufkraftsicherung und
sozialen Ausgleich auch Perspektiven
schafft und deshalb hat der
Wirtschaftsminister zu Recht heute
morgen angekündigt dass wir die
Programme erweitern und öffnen werden
das Mittelstand und Industrie auch davon
profitieren und ich sage Herr Minister
wir müssen auch an die preissetzenden
Mechanismen dran so wie Gas und
Strompreise entstehen auf dem Markt
können wir nicht weiter zugucken das
können wir nicht kompensieren und
deshalb ist es gut wenn sie morgen im
Ministerrat in Brüssel darüber sprechen
mit unseren europäischen Freunden denn
wir sind in einem europäischen
Binnenmarkt und wir können es national
nicht alleine und vielleicht nehmen sie
als Idee noch mit einen europäischen
Industriepreis zu verankern das wäre
wirklich ein Fortschritt
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
die Reden von Frau Klöckner und gestern
von Herrn Merz muss ich sagen sie sind
wirklich Weltmeister im Problem
beschreiben diese Ampelkoalition ist
aber dabei dieses Land zu reagieren und
Probleme zu lösen und nicht nur zu
beschreiben und deshalb werden wir
deshalb werden wir in diesem
Bundeshaushalt und das um den geht es ja
hier in dieser Debatte naja also gestern
habe ich nur Zitate gehört und
irgendwelche Zeitungsartikel die ja
vorgelesen wurden keine vernünftigen
Konzepte wie man diesen
Wirtschaftsstandort in die Zukunft
entwickelt und das werden wir in der
Ampelkoalition machen
wir haben
wir haben hier eine Situation dass wir
mit Unternehmen
mit einer Transformation befindlich zu
tun haben die das Angebot erneuerbarer
Energien brauchen um eine Perspektive zu
haben das ist bei Stahlindustrie das ist
bei Chemie bei der Produktion von
Aluminium oder Kupfer der Fall und in
vielen anderen Bereichen habe gestern
erst im Harz mit einem Metall
erzeugenden Betrieb gesprochen der heute
mit Kokskohle und Strom die
Stahlschmelze organisiert der ist darauf
angewiesen erneuerbare Energien zu haben
und weil die Leitungsstruktur dort nicht
vorhanden ist bemüht er sich jetzt mit
Freiflächen Photovoltaikanlagen die
Energieversorgung zu organisieren mit
Wasserstoff auch die schwankende
Erzeugung das sind Unternehmen die
zuversichtlich anpacken und die Zukunft
organisieren um Arbeits- und
Ausbildungsplätze und Wertschöpfung zu
halten und das ist das was wir politisch
unterstützen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wir haben mit dem Bundeshaushalt fast
ein Drittel die Investitionen erhöht das
zeigt doch schon dass diese
Bundesregierung dabei ist Mittel zu
organisieren die eben genau Unternehmen
bei dem Investitionen unterstützen
flankieren wir haben sehr erfolgreiche
Programme mit dem Zimt was gerade abhebt
auf den Mittelstand wir haben mit der
GRW wie eben schon Frank junger darauf
hingewiesen ist ein Instrument wo wir
Regionen die wirtschaftlich zurück sind
helfen auch Anschluss zu halten und wir
haben weitere Potenziale die wir nicht
aus den Augen verlieren müssen und
deshalb sind in den
berichterstattergesprächen der
Haushälter vielleicht noch die Punkte
auch aufzunehmen mit dem ipsai die sehr
erfolgreich in den Bereichen
Zukunftstechnologien wie Wasserstoff
etabliert sind auch die Frage der
Gesundheitswirtschaft mit aufzuwirken
ist etwas was wir sehr erfolgreich haben
und weiterentwickeln können und
sicherlich auch die Luft und Raumfahrt
ist ein Bereich der uns hilft die
Zukunft zu gestalten meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
die SPD ist sehr nah an denen
Unternehmen und der Entwicklung sie
können sich sicher sein dass wir mit
Betriebsräten mit Gewerkschaften mit
Unternehmen mit Management sprechen und
deshalb werden die nächsten Wochen
entscheidend sein und diese
entlastungspakete die auf den Weg
gebracht worden sind haben wir auch noch
Optionen Anschlussprogramme zu
finanzieren und ich bin zuversichtlich
dass diese Bundesregierung die über
ihren kollisionsvertrag mehr
innovationswagen beschrieben hat genau
diese Politik verankert und deshalb bin
ich zuversichtlich auch den Menschen
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt und
Zukunft mit positiven Politik zu
begleiten vielen Dank
Bernd Westphal aus der SPD-Fraktion
deshalb wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher
ist folgt Carsten Hülse aus der
afd-fraktion ob man im Ausschuss für
Klimaschutz und Energie
[Applaus]
mache ich Frau Präsident meine Damen und
Herren liebe Landsleute der
Haushaltsentwurf zeigt sehr deutlich
dass sich die dümmste Energiepolitik der
Welt nicht nur auf fatale Weise den
Geldbörsen der Menschen und in den
Bilanzen der Unternehmer
widerspiegelt sondern auch im Haushalt
der durch die Grünen Kommunisten
angeführten Bundesregierung statt in
dieser fundamentalen und seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg schlimmsten
Wirtschaftskrise alle Mittel einzusetzen
um diese zu bewältigen wird das Geld der
Steuerzahler zum Fenster hinausgeworfen
Milliarden werden für grünkommunistische
Luftschloss ausgegeben die Mitstreiter
im Geiste NGOs und klebstoffsüchtige
Arbeitsschuhe Elemente alimentiert und
die Vernichtung der wertschöpfenden
Industrie in Deutschland vorangetrieben
viele Mittelständler gehen jetzt
reihenweise aufgrund der explodierenden
Energiepreise Pleite sie bekommen nach
den sinnlosen
lockdown-maßnahmen nun den Rest dank der
schon von vergangenen Regierungen
praktizierten und nun detaillierten
energieverknappungspolitik als
gegenrezept empfiehlt
wirtschaftszerstörer Robert Habeck allen
Ernstes die Unternehmen sollten doch
einfach aufhören zu produzieren aufhören
zu verkaufen dann müssten sie nicht in
die Insolvenz gehen dümmer geht immer
ihre Aufgabe ist es zu allererst Schaden
vom deutschen Volk abzufinden und seinen
Wohlstand zu mehreren sie tun das genaue
Gegenteil sie verknappen böswilliger
Absicht bezahlbare Energie wodurch die
schon vorher höchsten Energiepreise der
Welt nun durch die Decke gehen das
Abdrehen der Gasversorgung durch
Russland als Antwort auf Sanktionen
vertrags- und Wortbruch wirkt dabei nur
als Brandbeschleuniger denn sie sie
allein zusammen mit ihren willfährigen
Vorgänger Regierungen haben diesen Brand
gelegt und die Lunte schon vor vielen
Jahren gezündet Klimaschutz und
Energiewende nennen sie es in Wahrheit
wahr und ist es ein Programm zur
Zerstörung unserer Wirtschaft und
Verelendung des deutschen Volkes die AFD
hat diesen Irrweg von Anfang an kein
ideologisch begründet benannt es gibt
daher nur eine Richtung Kohleverstromung
Förderung deutschen schiefergases laut
Bundesbehörde 2,5 Billionen Kubikmeter
und natürlich Nutzung der Kerne gehen
lassen Sie die sichersten Kernkraftwerke
der Welt weiterlaufen fahren Sie
stillgelegten Kraftwerke wieder hoch die
die technischen und
Sicherheitsbedingungen erfüllen CDU und
FDP fordern allen Orten auch hier im
Parlament den Weiterbetrieb der
Kernkraftwerke unsere Fraktion ist
allerdings die einzige die einen
entsprechendes Gesetz eingebracht hat
sie können gemeinsam mit uns dieses
Gesetz beschließen tun sie es nicht
würden sie und das muss ich leider sagen
auch wenn ich einige ihrer Kollegen
Schätze sind sie nur erbärmliche Häuser
die zwar große Töne spucken aber im
entscheidenden Moment den Schwanz
einziehen die Menschen die für Frieden
Freiheit und Selbstbestimmung auf der
Straße sind beweisen dass man trotz
unterschiedlicher politischer Grund
überzeugend gemeinsam etwas erreichen
kann das Kippen der allgemeinen
Impfpflicht hat jedem Menschen gezeigt
es macht Sinn für seine Rechte zu
demonstrieren und ich hoffe dass sie in
diesem Herbst viele Menschen ihre Macht
bewusst werden und sie die Deutschland
Zerstörer hier auf der Regierungsbank in
die Schranken weisen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
ich muss einen kurz durchatmen aber uns
wir haben uns vereinbart uns nicht mit
irgendwelchen Titeln zu belegen und
erbärmliche Heuchler sollten wir uns
hier im Hause nicht gegenseitig nennen
bitte Sie in Zukunft auf ihre Wortwahl
zu achten erhilfe
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Reinhard Huben und
reinhardspolitischer Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
das Niveau der Debatte ist zum Teil
schon schwerlich zu ertragen aber Frau
Klöckner dass sie hier antreten und sich
über
Holzen in der Debatte beschweren
dann aber keine Zwischenfrage zulassen
und
dieser Regierung zu unterstellen wir
würden systematisch für die
Deindustrialisierung dieses Landes
sorgen zu wollen das ist afd-niveau Frau
Glöckner
und lieber Herr Spahn lieber Herr Spahn
16 Jahre ist ja für die FDP nicht das
Thema
aber die Bundesregierung für die
Bekämpfung der Krise in den letzten
sechs Monaten zu kritisieren
ist im Vergleich zur Professionalität
der Probleme zu corona-zeiten auch ein
bisschen schräg denn die Maßnahmen die
während der corona-maßnahmen getroffen
wurden haben den Mittelstand
bisher zumindest mehr geschadet als alle
Unternehmungen dieser Bundesregierung
der Energiekrise zu bekämpfen und es ist
uns vorgeworfen worden ja ihr habt ja
noch gar nichts gemacht
also ja die hören zu die hören zu
deswegen kommen sie nicht zum Klatschen
sie haben uns vorgeworfen sie hat ja
noch gar nichts gemacht das ist doch
Irrsinn das ist doch nur wirklich
Irrsinn wir bauen lng-terminals als
Zwischenlösung kommen die eva-us
wir kaufen wo möglich Gas ein wir
schieben an die Kohle
Stromversorgung das machen wir doch
alles Kohle wird eingekauft es ist doch
nicht so dass man ein Atomkraftwerk oder
ein Kohlekraftwerk einfach an und
ausschaltet sie müssen ja
beschaffungswege Sie müssen doch
beschaffungswege ermöglichen das ist
doch möglich es tut mir leid also Fragen
aus der AFD nehme ich gerade Fragen
gut und deswegen die beschaffungswege
sind eröffnet aber wissen Sie die Kohle
kommt doch nicht mit dem Flugzeug die
muss ja erstmal über eine Logistik auch
herangebracht werden und deswegen finde
ich diese Vorwürfe die sie hier machen
wirklich an der Realität vorbei
und
seien Sie gewiss wir haben am Donnerstag
die Maßnahmen debattiert als Ampel heute
am Sonntag die Fragen der Entlastung
debattiert heute ist Donnerstag morgen
wird es unter Umständen auf europäischer
Ebene eine Lösung geben also noch nicht
mal eine Woche und das als langsam zu
bezeichnen finde ich auch ein bisschen
schwierig eine letzte Bemerkung
Preisbildung
Preisbildung am Energiemarkt ich will es
mal unidologisch einführen wenn die OPEC
beschließt
im nächsten Monat die Ölförderung zu
steigern dann singt am nächsten Tag der
öl-weltmarktpreis
und so ist es eben auch beim Strom und
deswegen ist die FDP der festen
Überzeugung dass wir in dieser Notlage
die drei AKWs die uns zur Verfügung
stehen noch einmal mit Brennstäben
ausstatten und sie über anderthalb bis
drei Jahre entsprechend der Not dann
auch betreibt vielen Dank
[Applaus]
bevor ich die nächste Rednerin Aufrufe
hat dir das jetzt das Wort zu einer
Kurzintervention aus der afd-fraktion
Rainer Kraft ja vielen Dank Frau
Präsidentin Herr Huben ich komme nicht
umhin ganz kurz noch sie haben die Frau
glogne kritisiert dass sie keine
Zwischenfrage zugelassen hat sie haben
es dann selber gemacht nur eine
brandbemerkung wenn sie Kernkraft gut
finden wunderbar in zwei Wochen gibt es
ein gesetzesentwurfantrag meiner
Fraktion dazu der ist sehr simpel
gehalten den kann man zustimmen dann
läuft dann passiert genau das was Sie
möchten aber die eigentliche Frage ist
sie haben sehr viel vom LNG gesprochen
den fsa-news und deswegen die konkrete
Frage als sie als regierungstragende
Koalition wie viel unterschriebene
Kontrakte für wie viel Milliarden
normkubikmeter LNG Gas liegenden derzeit
vor wie viel ist bereits gekauft denn
erst dann kann das Gas bei den
Verbrauchern ankommen
sie dürfen Antworten
immer Fragen zu bin jetzt fünf Jahre in
diesem Hause
aber in den fünf Jahren hat sich ihre
Fraktion einfach derartig aus der
Debatte
herausgebrüllt und gepöbelt dass ich das
nicht machen möchte und das bitte ich
als persönliche Entscheidung zu
akzeptieren
sie fragen nach dem konkreten Zahlen
weiß ich nicht nein ich werde auch nicht
schätzen wir sind doch hier nicht bei
einer quizveranstaltung das
Wirtschaftsministerium arbeitet an den
Zahlen machen Sie eine kleine Anfrage an
den Wirtschaftsminister wird Ihre Frage
schon beantworten danke
[Applaus]
nächste Rednerin
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Lisa badum
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren wenn die
Beiträge aus der Union heute so gehört
hatte muss ich einfach nur sagen ich bin
wirklich froh dass sie nicht mehr in der
Regierung sind denn das Ausmaß des
Ausmaß der Realitätsverweigerung mit dem
Sie hier antreten mit wenn sie nicht
fähig Entscheidungen zu treffen und das
ist genau das was wir tun Entscheidungen
treffen auf der Basis von Fakten und was
die Atomenergie betrifft sind die klar
so gut wie kein Beitrag zur
gaseinsparung so gut wie kein Beitrag
zur Senkung des Strompreises und ein
geringer Beitrag in einem extremen
Notfall zur Sicherung der Netzstabilität
das ist die Wahrheit und da können Herr
Söder und Herr Merz noch so oft vor
dieser zwei posieren davon wird sich
nichts ändern
[Applaus]
und jetzt kommen wir zum klimaschutzjahr
jung denen die Union jetzt in dieser
Legislatur für sich entdeckt hat ich
begrüße das und sie haben natürlich
Recht der Verkehrsbereich muss mehr
liefern und deswegen haben wir 1,5
Milliarden mehr für die Schiene
eingestellt aber
klar ist klar ist es muss mehr kommen
und dann schlage ich einfach vor dass
die unionsregierten Länder heute schon
mal die Straßenbauprojekte nicht
benötigt werden an den Verkehrsminister
schicken das ist sicher eine gute
Hilfestellung
es ist so
jetzt kommen wir aber zum Balken zum
Klimaschutz Bike in ihrem eigenen Auge
ein kongeniales Duo von Herr Altmaier
und ich weiß nicht wer damals
bayerischer Ministerpräsident war haben
ja die bayerische windkraftverweigerung
gestützt und Herr Dobrindt ist wundert
mich nicht dass ich heute nicht
anredepult trauen weil als fremden als
Bayern muss ich sagen diese
Wehleidigkeit dieses jammern wie sie nur
mit dem Finger nach Berlin zeigen das
geht mir so auf den Geist übernehmen sie
endlich Verantwortung für das Land
Bayern ist
bürgerenergieland bioenergie-land Bayern
kann windenergiland werden und wenn wir
es hier schaffen 10 Gesetze zu Energie
und Klima im Bundestag zu verabschieden
dann werden sie es wohl hinbekommen ein
energiewendegesetz zu verabschieden und
das ist die Abschaffung der zehnh-regel
in Bayern und zwar zackig das erwarten
wir
Lisa bardum aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen wo Sie ob Frau im Ausschuss
für Klimaschutz und Energie ist
bemängelt
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen in Bayern nächster
Redner ist hier Hans-jörg durtz aus der
Unionsfraktion ob man im
Wirtschaftsausschuss
für Politik gibt es viele Definitionen
doch einige ganz besonders in
Krisenzeiten und die lautet politik ist
die Kunst des Möglichen
wenn man diese Definition anwendet habe
ich große Zweifel ob die Ampel in dieser
Krise wirklich Politik gestaltet
denn sie weigert sich in einer der
größten Krisen dieses Landes alles zu
tun was möglich ist
und
und die völlig und die völlig vermurkste
gasumlage die auch noch die Inflation
anheizt
hat gezeigt wie weit es mit der
regierungskunst her ist
ob nun als zufallsgewinn Abschöpfung
oder ein neues Strom Marktdesign die von
ihnen angekündigten
Ideen brauchen nicht nur Zeit sondern
lösen nicht die Ursachen des
Preisanstiegs auf den Energiemärkten
sondern dämpfen allenfalls die Folgen
denn die größte Energiekrise seit
Jahrzehnten ist vor allem eines ein
angebotsschock und wie reagiert man
zuallererst auf einen angebotsschock man
muss dann das Angebot ausweiten und alle
möglichen Kapazitäten ohne ideologische
Scheuklappen ans Netz bringen
und es gilt eben auch für Biomasse und
es gilt eben auch für die befristete für
den befristeten Weiterbetrieb von
Atomkraft und wenn Sie uns das schon
nicht glauben dann können Sie zumindest
auf die FDP hören die das ja auch
einfordert
und die Wirtschaftsweisen
die übrigens folgendes auch gesagt haben
die Atomkraftwerke ans als Notreserve
einzusetzen mal abgesehen davon ob das
technisch überhaupt möglich ist steht ja
auch nur in der Diskussion aber sie als
notwendig Seife einzusetzen hat die
Wirtschaftsweise Veronika Grimm als die
schlechteste alle Möglichkeiten
bezeichnet weil man nämlich weiterhin
die Kosten hat aber kein Strom
produziert wird der eine positive
Wirkung auf den Strompreis hätte und
unsere Betriebe und Handwerker brauchen
dringend und zwar schnellstmöglich
niedrigere Strompreise
denn
er gut anhören sie halt auf die
Wissenschaft und die FDP die sehr wohl
alle der Meinung sind das ist sehr wohl
Wirkung auf den Strompreis hat
denn der Bäcker wird sein Brot nicht
erst dann nicht mehr backen können wenn
er gar keine Energie mehr hat sondern
dann wenn er zum Beispiel aufgrund der
Knappheit die extrem hohen Preise nicht
mehr bezahlen kann oder wenn er der
Preise nicht mehr weitergeben kann an
seinen Kunden und der einzige Ausweg ist
dann die Produktion zu stoppen und
Mitarbeiter nach Hause zu schicken ein
Vertreter meiner Handwerkskammer hat mir
an diesen Tagen gesagt im Handwerk
stirbt man still
ihre Aufgabe als Wirtschaftsminister ist
es deshalb das Angebot an Energie
auszuweiten allein schon um den immensen
Preissteigerungen entgegenzuwirken denn
einer der einfachsten
volkswirtschaftlichen Lehrsätze lautet
Angebot hoch dann singt der Preis und da
hilft jede zusätzliche Kilowattstunde
darüber hinaus sind
Unterstützungsmaßnahmen mit Sicherheit
auch notwendig Energiekosten
dämpfungsprogramm ist im Grundsatz
richtig nur wirkt es nicht und wirkt es
vor allem nicht für die kleinen
mittelständischen Unternehmen sie haben
angekündigt dass sie dort jetzt mit
einem Rettungsschirm agieren wollen
allerdings hätten sie über Monate Zeit
gehabt den auch vorzubereiten das heißt
es wird jetzt endlich Zeit dass dieser
auch umgesetzt wird sie müssen handeln
auch beim Strom insbesondere auch
Verkleidung mittelständische Unternehmen
und um einem angebotsschock zu begegnen
braucht es in einer sozialen
Marktwirtschaft dringend auch Innovation
und Leistung der Haushaltsentwurf zeigt
in innovativen Bereichen auch Kürzungen
darüber müssen wir in den
Haushaltsberatungen reden das kann nicht
sein im Grunde im Gegensatz dazu
übrigens ist der Haushaltsposten
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit des bmwk deutlich
angestiegen bedienen sie sich nicht
allein der Kunst des Redens sondern vor
allem der Kunst des Möglichen vielen
Dank
Hans-jörg durz aus der CSU Landesgruppe
Obmann im Wirtschaftsausschuss des
Deutschen Bundestages der den Einzelplan
09 des Haushalts
2023 diskutiert bzw den ersten Entwurf
für das Haushaltsgesetz 2023 und in
dieser Debatte ist jetzt die dritt
letzte Rednerin dran Nina Scheer aus der
SPD-Fraktion Sprecherin für Klimaschutz
und Energie
und Kollegen
im Bett beginnen mit ein paar Fakten aus
dem Haushalt die ganz klar eines
erkennen lassen auch wenn natürlich über
das letzte Wochenende noch mal weitere
Haushaltstitel angeklungen sind die dann
noch im weiteren zu aufzugreifen sein
werden wir haben einen kräftigen
aufwuchs gegenüber dem letzten Jahr und
wir haben in zentralen Bereichen auch
den internationalen klimaschutzbereichen
einen Zuwachs wir haben
Investitionsanreize mit Zusatz das zimt
ist mit Zuwachs versehen allerdings
haben wir auch tatsächlich noch ein
bisschen klärungsbedarfe wie das eben
ist auch für ein ordentliches
parlamentarisches Verfahren gehört dass
dazu auch bei der neuen Mobilität bei
den grb-mmitteln und auch noch bei
Auslandsinvestitionen um nur einige
Sachen zu nennen ich möchte aber auch
erwähnen dass wir mit dem KTF also dem
Klima transformationsfonds über einen
Jahreszeitraum einen den Zeitraum von
2023 bis 26 und das fällt dann leicht
hinten runter wenn man einfach nur im
jahreshäppchen rechnet dass wir da
177,5 Milliarden Euro investieren wollen
und das ist natürlich schon eine
Hausnummer die unmittelbar anknüpft an
das was sich im Übrigen in der
Gesetzesmaterie tut und da haben wir
schon eine ganze Menge im ersten
Halbjahr auf den Weg gebracht selbst
wenn wir viele notfallgesetze machen
mussten mit dem brustpaket sind auch mit
einer großen EEG-Novelle viele Hemmnisse
abgebaut werden für erneuerbare Energien
viele Hemmnisse abgebaut worden und
weitere Hemmnis abbauten werden auch
noch kommen mit den nächsten Paketen
und zu Wahrheit gehört eben auch dass
wir hier enorm viel aufzuräumen haben
wir haben es ja auch schon in der großen
Koalition erlebt wie mühselig es war
Fortschritte für erneuerbare Energien
reinzuverhandeln auszuverhandeln die
Gegenwehr zurückzudrängen die leider in
den reinen cdu/csu über Jahre vorhanden
waren das war ein mühseliges Geschäft
und häufig sind darüber Kompromisse
entstanden die wenigstens ein bisschen
mehr Wert für die Erneuerbaren
bedeuteten aber häufig auch Komplexität
geschaffen haben und das jetzt alles so
zurückzudrehen dass wir tatsächlich
diesen Booster für die Erneuerbaren
hinkriegen den wir brauchen das ist
wirklich auch kein einfaches Unterfangen
und in diesem Sinne haben wir schon eine
ganze Menge geleistet
[Applaus]
man muss dazu sagen wenn wir jetzt im
Moment darauf schauen wie kriegt man die
Versorgungssicherheit gewährleistet dann
haben wir natürlich einmal die
finanzielle Fähigkeit einer Gesellschaft
die es zu stärken gilt da haben wir
jetzt mit der Vereinbarung über das
dritte Entlastungspaket schon einen
weiteren dicken meilenstein-gesetz den
es in die Umsetzung zu überführen gilt
wir haben aber natürlich auch die
weitere Fähigkeit
aus der Gesellschaft heraus mit den
Unternehmen aus den Unternehmen heraus
mit entsprechenden Rahmenbedingungen
auch sich weiter aus der führe
herausführen zu können deswegen muss das
miteinander verzahnt werden einmal
zielgenau und möglichst wirklich
zielgenau auch dort wo der Schuh am
meisten drückt sowohl bei den
Unternehmen als auch bei den privaten
Haushalten anzusetzen mithilfen aber
zeitgleich eben auch die Weichen immer
weiter ein Stückchen weiter zu öffnen in
Richtung Transformation in Richtung
erneuerbare Energien und hier möchte ich
auch betonen klar wir haben eine Menge
erneuerbaren Energien Ausbaubedarf das
ist ohnehin auf unserem Zettel auf
unserem Habenseite vielen
Gesetzesänderungen die wir schon gemacht
haben aber wir können auch wenn wir
jetzt akut uns überlegen wie können wir
noch mehr Energie reinbringen in den
Markt dann haben wir auch noch eine
ganze Menge schon installierten
erneuerbare Energien es liegt noch
weiter ausgelastet werden können wir
haben zum Beispiel Nacht Absenkung für
Windkraftanlagen die sind Lärm bedingt
durchaus in gewissen Rahmen sinnvoll
aber jetzt in der Krisenzeit kann man
sehr wohl überlegen lasst uns daran wir
brauchen wir können diese Potenziale
brauchen sie sind installiert das
gleiche bei Bioenergie natürlich und das
hat da braucht sonst auch nicht cdu/csu
erst drauf zu bringen das ist natürlich
schon längst auf dem Zettel das ist
schon längst in Arbeit da brauchen wir
keine Nachhilfe das ist schon längst in
Arbeit
und sie wissen auch ganz genau deswegen
der verweiser jung ich glaube Sie haben
es erwähnt dass da jetzt noch mit dem
Antrag irgendetwas wird wir eine
Entscheidungshilfe bräuchten von ihrer
Seite mit irgendwelchen Anträgen die in
der haushaltswoche ohnehin nicht ziehen
nein diese Dinge sind das wissen sie
auch ganz genau sie wollten
wahrscheinlich jetzt so so so so wirken
als ob sie schneller sein aber wie
gesagt es ist haushaltswoche danach in
den nachfolgenden Wochen werden solche
Anträge wieder behandeln und dann haben
wir natürlich eine Überarbeitung des
energiesicherungsgesetzes und das zeigt
auch die Handlungsfähigkeit der
Koalition und im Rahmen dessen wird
natürlich auch weiter an den
Befähigungen in Richtung erneuerbare
Energienutzung gearbeitet vielen Dank
Nina Scheer aus der SPD-Fraktion hat
gleich mehrere Abkürzungen verwendet in
ihrem Redebeitrag ein will ich Ihnen
auflösen Tim das ist das zentrale
Investitionsprogramm Mittelstand eins
der Förderprogramme des
Bundeswirtschaftsministeriums und
ungefähr in acht neun Minuten geht's
hier weiter mit dem Einzelplan
Gesundheit und der zuständige Minister
ist wie Sie sehen auch schon da Karl
Lauterbach wir schauen zurück ans Pult
da steht Andreas Mattfeld aus der
Unionsfraktion Mitglied im
Haushaltsausschuss
da wirklich ein bisschen demütiger in
diesen Tagen ihre ihre
Selbsteinschätzung zu Beginn ihrer Rede
Herr Habeck ich darf Ihnen das sagen die
hat mich fassungslos gemacht fassungslos
gemacht wie sie sich selber sehen und
wie die realen Ergebnisse sind die sie
hier vorzuweisen haben und dabei habe
ich Ihnen im Frühjahr gesagt dass ich
sie nicht um ihren Job beneide ich habe
ihnen sogar Respekt gezollt weil ich den
Eindruck hatte dieser Mann stellt
Parteipolitik hinten ran und ich habe
sie hierfür sogar öffentlich gelobt was
in meiner Fraktion nicht so gut ankam
das darf ich ganz deutlich sagen ich bin
selten so enttäuscht worden wie von
ihnen her Habeck das darf ich in aller
Öffentlichkeit sagen und ich sage Ihnen
denn nur der Publicity wegen agiert
wer hinterher nicht liefert der wird das
Vertrauen der Menschen schneller
verlieren als er sich selbst vorstellen
kann und deshalb auf eine anständige
Performance und die geben sie wirklich
hoffentlich ab da muss vor allen Dingen
eine gute aber auch schnelle Umsetzung
erfolgen nur mit quatschen nur mit
medialen Auftritten da haben sie Herr
habe ich noch kein Problem gelöst und
dass der Maischberger Auftritt totaler
Quatsch und total lost war ich glaube
das hassen sie haben sie selbst gemerkt
in so einer existenziellen Krise wie
sich unser Land seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg nicht mehr erlebt hat da
dürfen einfach handwerkliche Fehler und
Versäumnisse in dieser Art nicht
passieren das sind bei ihnen
keine Einzelfälle mehr ja frau
Präsidentin entschuldigung
es gibt eine Frage oder
Zwischenbemerkung aus der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sie dürfen
über Kollege Mattfeld vielen Dank wo sie
das jetzt gerade ansprechen würde ich
gerne sie fragen ob sie zur Kenntnis
nehmen wollen zu Beginn der
Ampelkoalition als wir das hier
übernommen haben
dass dort geplant war Nord Stream 2 in
Betrieb zu nehmen das dort die
Gasspeicher so leer waren wie eigentlich
im Jahresdurchschnitt nie im Oktober
letzten Jahres viel zu wenig Gas war
eingespeichert und dass sie in den
letzten 16 Jahren die erneuerbaren
Energien blockiert haben statt
vorangebracht und deswegen stehen wir da
wo wir jetzt stehen
und wollen sie zur Kenntnis nehmen das
Nord Stream 2 jetzt gestoppt ist dass
derzeit sogar nicht mal mehr durch Nord
Stream 1 Gas fließt dass die Gasspeicher
so gut gefüllt sind wie im
Jahresdurchschnitt seit langem nicht
mehr und dass diese ampelregierung noch
vor dem Sommer ein massives
Gesetzespaket zur Beschleunigung der
erneuerbaren Energien umgesetzt hat das
sind so viele Gesetze wie selten ein
anderes Ministerium in so kurzer Zeit
umgesetzt hat wollen Sie diese
Leistungsbilanz zu Kenntnis nehmen
heimatfeld ich freue mich sehr Frau Dr
Christmann dass sie mir diese Frage
stellen insbesondere zu Nord Stream und
jetzt sage ich mal Nord Stream 2 da gibt
es auch Nord Stream 1 und wollen sie zur
Kenntnis nehmen das nordstream 1 ihre
Erfindung ist sie Nord Stream 1 mit an
den ich sage es mal an die Versorgung
gebracht haben das war zu ihrer
Regierungszeit insofern auf andere
Finger zeigen hilft hier in diesem Fall
überhaupt überhaupt nicht sie haben dann
und diese Frage mir zu stellen diese
Frage mir zu Gast speichern zu stellen
das ist schon eine Frechheit diese Frage
müssen sie ihren Koalitionspartner
Stellen
2014 hat euer Wirtschaftsminister Sigmar
Gabriel die Gasspeicher in Reden die
erdgaskonzessionen in Niedersachsen an
Gazprom verkauft ich war seinerzeit
Mitglied der Regierungskoalition und das
macht man sehr selten dass man als
Mitglied hören Sie doch zuerballer dass
man als Mitglied einer
regierungstragenden Koalition den
eigenen Wirtschaftsminister kritisiert
warum er das in dieser Phase gemacht hat
wir erinnern uns 2014 ist gerade die
Krim überfallen wurden und der SPD dem
Wirtschaftsminister Gabriel fällt nichts
anderes ein als den gaststreicher Reden
an Gazprom zu verkaufen ich habe dafür
einen Skandal gehalten
und sie haben noch eine dritte Frage
gestellt die mindestens die Präsidentin
hat das ja zugelassen diese mehr davon
wir hätten bei Windenergie nichts getan
Frau Dr Christmann
2005 waren wir wenn ich es richtig weiß
bei fünf Prozent sind Energiestrom heute
in den Jahren danach sind wir bei 50 im
Moment über 50 Prozent das hat diese
Regierungskoalition mit Partnern die
auch hier in der Mitte sitzen die Geld
waren auch gemacht und wenn ich das
sagen darf ich war viele Jahre
Altbürgermeister fast zehn Jahre wir
haben uns größte Mühe wir haben uns
größte Mühe gegeben Wind Energie
auszuweisen es waren ihre Leute allzu
häufig vor Ort die das verhindert haben
und deshalb her
Minister Habeck was für erleben sind
keine Einzelfälle die gasumlage die ist
mit Verlaub solch ein Murks gewesen sie
wäre gar nicht notwendig gewesen weil
sie mit dem Wirtschaft
Stabilisierungsfonds eine Instrument
haben wie sie dieses Problem zu einem
Großteil hätten lösen können eine
weitere Luftnummer das war doch die
Energiepartnerschaft mit Katar die nicht
vorankommt nicht ein Kubikmeter Gast
wurde hier ratifiziert und konnte zu
einer Entspannung der Märkte beitragen
der Gaspreis Herr Habeck der ist auch
dadurch durch die Decke gegangen weil
sie auch in Norwegen in Kanada nichts
erreicht haben und vom abrupten Stopp
ihrer co2-gebäude-sanierung der redet
schon keiner mehr und deshalb es ist
schon verwunderlich sie präsentieren uns
in diesen Tagen jetzt einen
Haushaltsentwurf in dem sie sogar die
wirtschaftsenergi und Klimapolitik
gegeneinander ausspielen das ist
übrigens auch gegenüber den 10.000 38
Mitarbeiter müssen uns auf der Zunge
zergehen lassen über 10.000 Mitarbeitern
in Geschäftsbereich nicht fair sie haben
jetzt für 2023 für das harbeckhaus 13
Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung im Entwurf
das sind 1,7 Milliarden Euro mehr als
2022 die ausgabereste türmen sich auf
mittlerweile über zwei Milliarden Euro
auf und natürlich geht bei Ihnen auch
die
stellenausweitungsorgie noch wieder
munter weiter noch einmal bringen sie 49
stellen und top auf wobei sie den
nachgeordneten Behörden zugunsten ihres
Mutterhauses sogar noch Stellen
wegnehmen Herr Habeck es ist schon
seltsam ich komme jetzt noch mal zum
paar Punkten im Haushalt da gibt es eine
Verliererseite das ist bei Ihnen im
Hause ganz klar die Mittelstandspolitik
der sie 56 Millionen Euro also gut fünf
Prozent streichen bei der
Außenwirtschaft die für den Export zur
existenziell wichtig ist streichen Sie
286 Millionen Euro also fast ein Drittel
bei der deutschen Zentrale für Tourismus
die wollen sie anscheinend kaputt
schießen kürzen Sie wieder 5 Millionen
das sind fast 30% weniger als noch bei
Herrn Altmaier und den Bereich Luft und
Raumfahrt aber eben 59 Millionen Euro
und bei der lehrlingsunterweisung und
bei Fortbildungseinrichtung für
Auszubildende wird der Rotstift auch
noch mal richtig angesetzt
der Arbeit sie haben natürlich auch eine
Gewinnerseite das ist beispielhaft die
Investition die Investition zum Schutz
der Biodiversität im Ausland im Ausland
dir hält über 685 Millionen Euro mehr
obwohl bislang in diesem Jahr lediglich
magere 110 Millionen abgeflossen sie
haben auch kryptisches das ist die
energiepolitische Zusammenarbeit mit der
Ukraine die wird erneut mit 50 Millionen
Euro angesetzt obwohl bislang kein Euro
abgeschlossen ist gleiches gilt für den
wirtschaftsfonds Afrika eigentlich eine
tolle Sache aber 10 Millionen Euro und
keine Abflüsse im laufenden Jahr da
frage ich mich was da los oder was ist
da besser nicht los bei Ihnen und
deshalb Herr Habeck ich würde mir wenn
ich Wirtschaftsminister wäre schon die
Fragen stellen ist das jetzt der
richtige Moment bei den Lehrlingen in
unserem Land zu kürzen Stichwort
schlimmster Fachkräftemangel ever ist
das jetzt der richtige Moment bei der
gebeutelten Tourismuswirtschaft noch
einmal zu kürzen Stichwort Umsatzausfall
durch Corona und ist das jetzt der
richtige Moment bei der wertschöpfenden
Industrie und bei Hochtechnologien zu
kürzen Stichwort Wettbewerbsfähigkeit in
einer globalen Wirtschaft für Harbeck
sie können nicht für die globale
Gesamtlage etwas sie wirken aber das
darf ich Ihnen sagen krisenverstärkend
und nach 14 Haushalten in ihrem
Ministerium darf ich sagen das ist das
Schlimmste der schlimmste Entwurf den
ich in 14 Hausarzt Jahren für das bmwk
erlebt habe eigentlich müsste dieser
Haushalt noch einmal mit Blick auf die
derzeitige Krise ganz neu aufgestellt
werden herzlichen Dank
Andreas Mattfeld aus der Unionsfraktion
und weil er seine Zeit als Bürgermeister
erwähnt hat Andreas Mattfeld kommt aus
dem Wahlkreis 34 Osterholz Verden das
ist natürlich Niedersachsen und in
Niedersachsen ist am 9 Oktober
Landtagswahl Lena Werner ist die letzte
Rednerin in dieser Debatte noch mal aus
der SPD-Fraktion
wirtschaftsrelevanten Aspekt eingehen
und zwar den Tourismus hat der Kollege
ja auch gerade schon aufgegriffen
natürlich sind Urlaubsreisen und
Restaurantbesuche eine Art Luxusgut und
in Krisenzeiten ist das wahrscheinlich
das erste worauf man dann verzichtet
aber wir brauchen alle mal eine Auszeit
und das kann ganz unterschiedlich sein
es kann eine Wandertour durch die Eifel
sein das kann ein Städtetrip sein ein
Strandurlaub oder eben auf dem
Campingplatz nebenan und gerade in
diesen Zeiten der Krise ist das für
unsere mentale Gesundheit besonders
wichtig und unsere Gesellschaft befindet
sich schon zu lange im krisenmodus die
gesamte Tourismusbranche wurde in den
letzten beiden Jahren hart getroffen
erst die corona-pandemie mit
weitreichenden Folgen und nun folgt
direkt eine Energiekrise und eine
Inflation dazu kommt er seit Jahren
wachsende Arbeitskräftemangel umso
wichtiger ist es jetzt dass wir
weiterhin Geld in unsere touristische
Infrastruktur investieren um sich
zukunftsfähig zu machen
[Applaus]
dazu zählt die Unterstützung vielen Dank
Herr Kollege der deutschen Zentrale für
Tourismus die zentrales maßgeblich für
das Marketing für den Tourismusstandort
Deutschland zuständig und für einen gut
funktionierenden Tourismus braucht es
neben Marketing der aber auch die
entsprechende Infrastruktur und
Rahmenbedingungen und als
Querschnittsbranche wird der Tourismus
von den Vorhaben der Koalition
maßgeblich profitieren
durch den Ausbau des ÖPNV und dem
vorhergesehenen vorgesehenen
bundesweiten Anschlussticket für das
9-euro-ticket schaffen wir ein
bezahlbaren und unkomplizierten
Nahverkehr und dessen Nutzung ist eben
für Einheimische aber auch Gäste sehr
attraktiv durch die Modernisierung der
Einwanderungsgesetze und der Stärkung
der dualen Ausbildung bekämpfen wir den
Fachkräftemangel und schaffen
Erleichterung in der Tourismuswirtschaft
und das Gastgewerbe in der Krise
weiterhin zu entlasten haben wir uns
darauf geeinigt die Reduzierung der
Umsatzsteuer auf Speisen zu verlängern
das schafft Planungssicherheit für die
Gastronomie und hier möchte ich mich vor
allem noch mal bei unserem Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz dafür bedanken
auch von der Kulturförderung des Bunde
profitierter Tourismus maßgeblich die
Aufrechterhaltung und Pflege unserer
Kulturdenkmäler sowie die vielfältige
deutsche Kulturlandschaft sind für viele
Besucher in entscheidende Faktoren
Deutschland zu bereisen und deshalb ist
es umso bedeutsamer dass das
Bundesprogramm Neustart Kultur
verlängert wurde davon profitiert die
Veranstaltungswirtschaft und der ganze
Kulturbereich und einen letzten Punkt
möchte ich noch erwähnen es ist auch
weiterhin ausschlaggebend dass wir in
anderen Ländern besonders im globalen
Süden finanziell unterstützen der
Tourismus ist nicht nur bei uns eine
starke Wirtschaftskraft für viele Länder
trägt dazu nachhaltigen Entwicklung und
finanziellen Unabhängigkeit bei das ist
für feministische Entwicklungspolitik
und deshalb ist es elementar dass
Deutschland weiterhin an internationalen
Projekten zur nachhaltigen
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung sich
beteiligt und damit stärken wir den
Tourismus eben auch weltweit vielen Dank
Lena Werner war die letzte Rednerin in
der ersten Beratung des Einzelplans 09
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz der Etat des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers Robert Habeck